Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, hau rein, hau rein, hau rein, hau rein, hau rein, hau rein, hau rein.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, hau rein, hau rein, hau rein.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, hau rein.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, hau rein, hau rein.
Das war's für heute.
Twitch-Benachrichtigung hyperfast, ja, die sind deutlich schneller als der Bot.
Der Bot, der ist teilweise ein ziemlicher Aussetzer.
Ich glaube, da müssen wir uns auch mal irgendeinen anderen Bot raussuchen.
Ich weiß nicht, warum der nicht richtig funktioniert.
Der Bot ist wirklich gaggel, Alter.
Der Bot ist eigentlich permanent hier so unterwegs.
Was? Teilweise halbe Stunde später?
Vielleicht werde ich den Stream heute auch als Hintergrund benutzen.
Ein paar Ausschnitte aus dem Stream im Hintergrund benutzen.
Sollte ich dazu ein YouTube-Video machen?
Zumindest mal ein paar Sachen, weil dann muss ich die Hardware nicht zweimal aufschrauben und so was.
Wenn wir uns das jetzt zusammen angucken.
Ob ich den Chat jetzt rein mache? Eher nicht.
Leute, solange das Stream startet, soll ich euch mal die fertig eingerichtete Delux-Kiste zeigen?
Das, wo wir die letzten paar Streams dann rumgebaut haben.
Ich habe auf Stream noch ein bisschen weiter gemacht.
Was heißt fertig? Fertig ist das Ganze natürlich nie.
Fertig ist das Ganze natürlich.
Fertig werden solche Dinger nicht.
Ich zeige euch jetzt aber was richtig cooles.
Guckt mal, ich habe jetzt Chat-GPT.
Chat-GPT bei mir auf der Kommandozeile.
Chat-GPT, könnt ihr irgendwas fragen von der Stelle aus?
Zum Beispiel das hier, was ich vorhin schon mal ausprobiert habe.
Explain this command rsync-va info progress.
Also, ich weiß, was das Kommando macht.
rsync-v ist mehr Detail-Infos.
a ist Archiv-Modus.
Da bleiben Permissions und so etwas gleich.
Und progress ist, dass man angezeigt bekommt, bei welchem Status er gerade ist.
Transfer.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, was Chat-GPT dazu sagt.
Der braucht ein bisschen.
Chat-GPT ist ja nicht das allerschnellste.
Aber meistens taugen dafür die Antworten.
Man kann es leider nicht genau einschätzen, ob es taugt.
Post-Champ?
Dead.
Wrong.
Nochmal abbrechen.
Fragen wir mal was anderes.
Explain Cackle.
Okay, der hat keinen Bock.
Der will nicht.
Chat-GPT denkt sich Nope.
Es kann auch sein, dass Chat-GPT gerade überlastet ist.
Das passiert ja.
Chat.
Das passiert ja immer wieder.
Normalerweise würde es dann.
Ich überlege gerade.
Hat das mein Login irgendwie vergessen oder so?
Was auch immer.
Woll ich mir mal anprobieren.
Ich habe noch was anderes.
Ich habe zwei Chat-GPT-Hilftools am Start.
Einmal kann man direkt Chat-GPT fragen.
Also wahrscheinlich.
Ich habe vorhin.
Ach, jetzt geht es.
Okay, ich habe meine Session vorhin gelöscht.
Deswegen geht das nicht.
Deswegen funktioniert das.
Okay, das leuchtet natürlich ein.
Und ich habe noch was anderes mit der Chat-GPT API.
Kannst du zum Beispiel fragen.
How to sync.
Keine Ahnung.
Tool.
Two directories.
On Linux.
Das geht jetzt über die API und kostet Geld.
Das da oben emuliert Chat-GPT mit einer Browser-Session.
Kostet kein Geld.
Geht natürlich auch viel schneller.
Das ist quasi die AI, die dahinter steckt von GitHub Copilot.
Und das hier oben ist direkt so ein CLI-Tool für Chat-GPT.
Das unten geht auch viel schneller.
Ask how to sync.
Das ist gar nicht schlecht.
Das ist relativ gut.
Leider hat Copilot keine Sessions, wo ich ihn fragen kann.
Explain this command.
Das kann ich dann mit Chat-GPT machen.
Chat-GPT kann ich fragen.
Explain this command.
Funktioniert aber nicht, weil meine Session kaputt ist.
Zumindest habe ich mir gedacht, ohne AI auf der Kommandozeile geht gar nichts.
Muss ja sein.
Also das hier ist tendenziell für Kommandos.
Kannst du der AI da noch Aufgaben geben?
Nee, ich kann die fragen.
Ich kann die fragen.
Die Chat-GPT-Antworten sind potenziell besser als die von Copilot.
Also das hier ist Copilot.
Das ist Chat-GPT.
Die Antworten von Copilot sind oft mal schneller und präzise auf den Punkt.
Chat-GPT sind aber umfangreicher und eigentlich besser.
Leider bin ich gerade nicht eingeloggt.
Ich könnte mich kurz einloggen bei Chat-GPT.
Da muss ich euch einfach mal...
Okay.
Ich switche euch einfach mal kurz um auf die Kamera.
Hallo, Chat.
Ihr dürft jetzt gerade nicht nachgucken.
Chat-GPT login.
So, ich logge mich mal kurz ein.
Ich glaube, jetzt hat es funktioniert.
Okay.
Erst jetzt hat es funktioniert.
Ich schalte euch wieder um.
Okay.
Jetzt hat es funktioniert.
So, jetzt kann ich nämlich sagen, Chat-GPT...
Explain 0W.
Beste Frage.
Gucken, ob es das weiß.
LUL ist eine commonly used emote in Online-Communication.
An der Stelle kann man übrigens auch sagen, hier...
Answer in German.
Man kann auch, gleich Frage...
Erkläre die Herkunft von LULW.
Nicht, dass man das jetzt irgendwie brauchen würde.
Alles fit?
Jo, wir bauen heute Emulator-Kiste.
LULW ist eine Abkürzung, die in der Online-Gaming-Community
und im Streaming-Fest steht für...
Siehste?
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Was viel interessanter ist...
Man kann z.B. hier fragen...
Man kann CodePilot fragen...
Man kann das verbinden.
Man kann CodePilot fragen, how to sync to directories.
Siehste?
Das würde ich jetzt so ohne Weiteres nicht machen.
Delete sorgt nämlich dafür, dass im Destination-Directories
Sachen gelöscht werden, die es im Source nicht mehr gibt.
Aber jetzt kann ich sagen, Chat-GPT...
Erklär mir mal das hier, please.
Guck.
Und...
Erklärte mir sogar die einzelnen Parameter, was die machen.
A ist Archive-Mode, V ist Verbose-Mode.
Eigentlich ziemlich cool, oder?
Es ist fast schneller wie Explain Shell.
Und man kann Chat-GPT auch auf Deutsch fragen.
So, keine Ahnung.
Wie...
Lass mal ein bisschen was Komplizierteres machen.
Wie aktiviere ich SSH-Multiplexing in der Config?
Wenn es das weiß, ist Sixhead.
Vor allem auf Deutsch.
Okay.
Nicht schlecht.
Das trifft.
Das stimmt.
Gut, das da hinten kann man nennen, wie man will.
Das ist eigentlich schon relativ gut.
Für solche Sachen ist es aber wirklich nice.
Chat-GPT labert immer unglaublich viel.
Das hört immer überhaupt nicht auf.
Das reicht eigentlich schon.
Das ist alles, was ich bräuchte.
Aber Chat-GPT schreibt immer einen halben Roman dazu.
Blablabla.
Ich mein, ich könnte einfach abbrechen.
Das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Und was hab ich die Woche so verpasst?
Gab es irgendwas Spannendes?
Bisschen laut.
Wie es C++ findet?
Okay.
Wie findest du C++?
Das kann sein, dass ich das quaten muss.
Ich kann mir schon denken, was die sagen.
Genau.
Die sagt wieder ihr übliches Ding.
Das antwortet immer so.
Nach dem Motto, ich kann dazu persönlich sagen.
C++ ist eine sehr mächtige und fies...
Okay, wir müssen anders fragen.
Warum ist C++ so kacke?
Ach ja, ach ja.
Das ist wohl wahr.
Es ist wichtig zu beachten, dass die Meinungen,
was über eine Programmiersprache subjektiv sind
und von der Erfahrung und Anführung das Einzelne abhängt.
Das macht das Ding immer so super ausgeglichen.
Okay, probieren wir mal.
Wir machen das mal auf Deutsch.
Generiere eine Liste C++.
Oh, ich habe mich verschrieben.
Mal gucken, ob es das checkt.
Okay, nicht schlecht.
Okay.
Antworten in...
Muss man vielleicht noch mal explizit dazu sagen?
Oh, das geht nicht.
Jetzt, ich habe mich verschrieben.
Deswegen hat es es nicht auf Deutsch gemacht.
C++ ist eine sehr hohe Leistung für Systemprogrammierer
und Anwendung mit hohen Anforderungen an die Rechenleistung.
Hohe Anforderungen an die Rechenleistung.
Okay, das würde ich so nicht sagen.
Das klingt sehr durch die Brust ins Auge formuliert, aber gut.
C++ hat eine steepere Lernkurve als andere Sprachen.
Oh, das stimmt.
Die Lernkurve ist deutlich steeper als bei anderen Sprachen.
JET-GPT ist easy installierbar.
Es gibt jemanden, der die API nachgebaut hat
und ein Kommando-Zeilen-Tool dafür,
oder die API mitgesnifft im Browser und dann das Nach-...
Kommando-Zeilen-Tool nachgebaut.
Lukas, danke schön für den Zapp.
Aber eigentlich wollen wir heute eine Emulator-Kiste bauen.
Okay, fragen wir mal.
Was ist die beste Linux-Distribution für Spiele-Emulation?
Ich weiß nicht, was ich jetzt noch richtig schreiben könnte.
Die API ist public, aber die kostet was.
Es gibt keine einzige beste...
Das ist immer...
Die drücken das alles so super diplomatisch immer aus.
Lukas, mit einem Emulations-Station-Frontend.
Okay.
Arch, by the way.
Wir machen das heute auch mit Bartoszera.
Ich habe das übrigens im Titel falsch geschrieben, sehe ich gerade.
Soll ich vielleicht noch mal richtig schreiben?
So.
Alles klar.
Gut, jetzt haben wir...
Wir haben, glaube ich, JET-GPT jetzt genug gequält.
Ja, wir können...
Leute, wisst ihr was wir...
Okay, wir vergleichen das jetzt mal.
Wir vergleichen mal CodePilot und JET-GPT.
Copy ISO to USB-Stick on Linux.
DD-Command, das ist schon mal gut.
Ja, das ist gut so.
So kann man das machen.
Okay, Halskalle, Klammer, JET-GPT, das reicht jetzt.
Ich muss den Standard-Error-Gram hier irgendwie mal wegmachen.
Jedes Mal, wenn man Ctrl-Dings drückt.
Mal kurz gucken, wo habe ich hier meinen Alias dafür?
Ach so, ich kann sogar Translater in der Shell.
Kann ich euch auch gleich mal zeigen.
JET-GPT.
Ach nee, das funktioniert ja an der Stelle nicht.
Ha, Mist, weil das ja ein Alias ist.
Da müsste ich eine Funktion draus machen, dass ich es umleiten kann.
Na egal.
Okay, also wir haben JET-GPT gerade gefragt, sagt DD.
So, How to Copy ISO to USB-Stick on Linux.
Fast.
Western mit SSH-Default starten, das ist ganz einfach.
DD-ISO, ja, da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten, ob das so sinnvoll ist.
Mit 4M ist wahrscheinlich sinnvoller, aber okay.
Also man muss sagen, Copilot ist deutlich mehr auf den Punkt.
Sagt aber auch öfters, wenn es keine Ahnung hat.
JET-GPT schwätzt immer 3 Stunden rum, was du gar nicht wissen willst.
Okay, was soll ich fragen?
Frag es mal, wie man eine Windows-ISO unter Linux auf einen USB-Stick kopiert.
Okay, das ist natürlich high IQ.
How to create bootable Windows-USB-Stick on Linux.
Und wie?
Das ist einfach.
Du sagst change shell und dann minus S, glaube ich.
Ich glaube so, wir fragen JET-GPT gerade mal.
Ich glaube, das ist das richtige Kommando.
Dann änderst du deine default shell.
Okay, was erzählen sie uns?
There are few ways to create bootable USB-Stick on Linux,
but one of them is use-dd-Command.
Nein, das funktioniert nicht.
There are the two general steps inside USB.
Siehste, JET-GPT erzählt halt einfach Mist.
Das stimmt schlicht und ergreifend nicht.
Ja, das funktioniert eher.
Das funktioniert nicht, was JET-GPT uns erzählt.
Wir fragen mal ARS, Co-Pilot.
Nein, die haben beide keine Ahnung davon.
Wir können sie fragen.
How to change your shell from bash.
Mal gucken.
You can use the command.
Siehste?
Leco, so funktioniert das.
Guck, guck.
So funktioniert das.
Und dann musst du dich neu einloggen,
und dann funktioniert das.
Okay, JET-GPT erhält vielleicht nicht die Klappe.
Also das muss man sagen,
JET-GPT-Antworten sind immer extrem ausschweifend.
Guck, Co-Pilot ist auf den Punkt, leckt mich.
Bam, so funktioniert es.
Und übrigens, das ist korrekt.
So würde ich es machen, so würde ich es nicht.
Also ich würde es so machen, wie Co-Pilot sagt,
und nicht wie JET-GPT sagt.
Ich muss jetzt sagen, unter der Haube ist da viel Gemeinsames,
aber im Detail unterscheiden sich die Antworten noch manchmal.
Genau, JET-GPT macht immer so auf schlau.
Ich kann übrigens auch direkt auf das DLI
translaten mittlerweile, volle AI-Power.
Wir können zum Beispiel übersetzen,
warum ist der Twitch-Chat heute so...
Das wird er nicht checken, aber okay.
Wow.
Okay.
Was geht?
Okay, das...
Okay, manchmal kackt es ein bisschen.
Warum ist der Twitch-Chat heute so cute?
Warum ist er...
Okay.
Why is the Twitch-Chat so smart today?
Okay, das passt.
Was geht?
What works?
Naja, gut, der hat halt überhaupt keinen Kontext.
Was geht ist eher so eine Frage, was ist los?
Aber das weiß er aus dem Kontext nicht.
Also man muss das, was man sieht,
man muss das alles immer doppelt und dreifach sich nochmal angucken,
ob das auch alles so passt.
Der Rest ist doch durchaus in Ordnung,
kann man sich doch nicht beschweren.
So, aber genug AI-Shit.
Guck mal, wie schön der Pepo durchschimmert hier im Hintergrund.
Seht ihr den?
White Pepo Happy.
Gibt es sonst noch Linux-Technisch was, was ich euch zeigen kann?
Ich habe meinen Rofi gethämt.
Guck, hier sieht er jetzt so aus.
Ich kann jetzt Programme starten,
grafische Anwendung starten, Windows switchen, Emojis einfügen.
Ich habe meinen Clipboard-Manager.
Ich kann ein paar spezielle Scripts starten, die ich mir reingehauen.
Zum Beispiel kann ich mein Clipboard an- und ausschalten,
was man dann da oben auch in der Leiste sieht,
wenn ich beispielsweise mal ein Passwort in Zwischenablage machen will.
Und man kann hier übrigens auch drinnen rechnen jetzt.
Weiß ich nicht, wie oft ich das verwenden werde.
Aber man weiß ja nie. Mal gucken.
Alles fertig gethämt.
Hast du nix zuerst schon mal ausgebildet? Nee, habe ich nicht.
Okay, Bato Serra Linux Download.
Ach so, wir laden uns jetzt mal kurz runter.
Und dann müssen wir ja nochmal auf die Kamera switchen.
Wir müssen uns die Kiste angucken.
Direct Link.
Während das runterlädt, switche ich schon mal rüber.
Und...
So.
Wir gucken uns das an.
Hast du dir das Chebat Video von Linus Tech Tips noch angeschaut? Nee.
Ich glaube, ich wurde aber schon gespoilert, um was es geht.
Nämlich, dass der wohl erzählt, Power Toys sind ganz nice und sowas.
Also eigentlich richtig harter Chebat wieder.
Wie kann man Ansible lernen, ohne sich eine Kiste in der Cloud zu mieten?
Geht das auch mit VM-Ware? Du brauchst weder VM-Ware noch was.
Du kannst einen Container starten.
Du kannst...
Aber dann keinen Docker-Container, sondern irgendwie einen LXT-Container,
wo du alles mögliche drin magst.
Du kannst eine VM installieren.
Kannst eine VM installieren, bietet sich sogar an.
Installiere eine VM und mach einen Snapshot,
dass du immer wieder zurück kannst zum Ausprobieren.
Du kannst Ansible überall laufen lassen.
Du kannst Ansible auch auf deiner lokalen Kiste laufen lassen
und Sachen ausprobieren.
Das ist unabhängig davon, ob das...
In der Regel führt man Ansible über SSH aus, aber das musst du nicht.
Kannst auch lokal machen.
Also du kannst auch lokal über SSH machen, so meine ich das.
VM-Ware Free hat keine Snapshots.
Dann musst du btrfs verwenden und selbst Snapshots machen.
Oder was auch immer.
Du löscht die eine Datei wieder.
Du kannst es doch auch im Container machen.
Es gibt jede Menge Möglichkeiten.
Was ist die einfachste Methode?
Also ich persönlich würde sagen, die einfachste Methode,
wenn man es drauf hat, ist irgendein LXT-Container,
falls du es schon drauf hast.
Du kannst es doch in einem Docker-Container machen.
Geht auch.
Wahrscheinlich ist ein Docker-Container am einfachsten.
Docker haben die meisten Leute installiert.
Neuer Job geht erst ab 01.04. los.
Du kannst auch einen Docker-Container starten, dich mit Shell reinconnecten
und dort dann Ansible ausführen.
Oder dich per SSH auf...
Wobei SSH auf Docker-Container ist ein bisschen schwierig,
da müsstest du SSH starten.
Wahrscheinlich ist es im Container am einfachsten.
Oder du machst dir eine VM.
Beides recht easy.
Du kannst aber auch lokal auf deiner Kiste testen.
Ist der neue PC schneller als ein Apple M2 Pro?
Ich denke, das hängt entscheidend vom Anwendungsbereich ab.
Es gibt wahrscheinlich
super optimierte Sachen,
die auf der Apple-Kiste schneller sind.
Aber das meiste 0.8.15-Zeug dürfte auf meinem schneller sein.
Also wenn du da jetzt zum Beispiel
in ein neues Spiel spielen willst,
dann ist das bei mir, voraus jetzt es würde überhaupt laufen dort,
bestimmt schneller.
Ja.
Kommt drauf an.
Das war so eine richtige Chat-GPT-Antwort, oder?
Es ist wichtig zu beachten,
dass es mehrere Möglichkeiten gibt,
was man unter am schnellsten bei einem PC verstehen kann.
In der Regel ist es so,
dass mit schneller die...
Chat-GPT hat so eine ganz spezielle Art und Weise,
wie es antwortet.
Was hast du zuletzt mit deinem 3D-Drucker gedruckt?
Gute Frage, ich schau ein bisschen her.
Wenn es mir jetzt nicht einfällt, wahrscheinlich ein Case.
Ach nee.
Ich hab noch eine zweite Variante hiervon gedruckt.
Guck mal.
Wisst ihr was das ist?
Das ist eine Lampe.
Guck.
Eine Lampe, da ist ein LED-Panel drinne
und ein Microcontroller.
Ich hab jetzt leider keinen Netzteil, um das anzuschließen,
sonst könnt ich es euch zeigen.
Und ich bin mir auch unschlüssig,
ob ich da einen Spannungswandler davor hab oder nicht.
Also vielleicht bräuchte ich da jetzt einen 5-Volt-Netzteil.
Wobei, ich versuch's euch mal zu zeigen.
Ich glaube, ihr guckt einen 5-Volt-Netzteil raus gerade.
Das reicht aber nicht, das ist zu kurz.
Warte mal, lass mich mal kurz um die Ecke gucken.
Nee, das reicht nicht, das reicht nicht.
Am besten hätte ich hier höchstens noch ein 12-Volt-Netzteil.
Das kann ich da auf keinen Fall anschließen,
sonst geht's wahrscheinlich kaputt.
Wartet mal, ich hab irgendwo ein 12-Volt-Netzteil.
Ich hab jede Menge, ich muss es nur finden.
Das müsste eigentlich eins sein, hier, lass mal kurz gucken.
Steht da was drauf? 5-Volt.
Output, 5-Volt, okay, sollte funktionieren.
5-Volt, 10 Ampere, das ist das fetteste Netzteil.
Das fetteste 5-Volt-Netzteil.
Das ist irgendwie nicht das Richtige zum reinstecken, oder?
Ich wollte grad sagen, irgendwas ist hier ein bisschen verkehrt.
Muss ich erst mal richtig dran machen noch.
Wartet mal, wir sind jetzt ein bisschen side-tracked gerade.
Was sein muss, muss sein, ja.
Muss ich grad mal kurz hier Kabel richtig rein machen.
Das ist definitiv ein Stecker, den man so nicht betreiben sollte,
sag ich euch gleich.
Aber meint man, 5-Volt stirbt keiner.
So, und jetzt könnte ich da drauf, jetzt könnte ich aufs Webinterface,
jetzt könnte ich aufs Webinterface, das sieht in der Kamera mega beschissen aus,
weil du in der Kamera die einzelnen Punkte siehst.
Wenn du das richtig einstellst und normal drauf guckst, siehst du die einzelnen Punkte gar nicht so krass.
Jetzt könnte ich ins Webinterface und da ein bisschen Zeug drinnen einstellen.
Das hab ich zuletzt gedruckt.
Also eigentlich schon cool, dass man so Dinger selbst drucken kann.
Sieht auch irgendwie ganz schick aus.
Das ist ein 16x16 LED-Matrix, genau.
Spooky Musik.
Gut.
Okay.
Letzte Woche ist der Toolcheck Plus angekommen.
Nice, beste. Hab ich auch im Schrank hängen drüben.
Wie lange hat's gedauert zu drucken? Oh, das Ding hat ein bisschen gedauert zu drucken.
Ich glaube, das hat bestimmt 5 Stunden oder so gedruckt, schon ein bisschen.
Dinos Tech-Tips, ich hab die bessere Variante hier.
Einen guten Swiss-Tool Multistells.
Gut, aber kommen wir mal zur eigentlichen Sache.
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, es war relativ lang gedruckt.
Naja, das Ding ist ja auch recht hoch.
Das ist eine 16x16, das könnten WS2812 LED sein.
Dein Headset rauscht, wenn du eine VM startest, das wundert mich, der Zusammenhang.
Kann das sein, dass du die Soundkarte in der VM nicht deaktiviert hast?
Und die komische Dinger macht beim Start?
Mach mal die Soundkarte, ich glaube nicht, dass es eine Störung ist.
Mach mal die Soundkarte aus der VM raus.
Und kam schon ein Kollege zu dir, dass du bitte deine Aufgaben erklären und übertragen sollst.
Ok, jetzt zeige ich euch mal die Kiste, auf der wir heute was installieren werden.
Und zwar den hier, guckt mal.
Und zwar ist das ein Mini.
Erkennt man was?
Ich muss mal kurz Fullscreen machen, sonst sehe ich gar nichts.
Kann man die Vorschau im OBS irgendwie Fullscreen machen?
Ja, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Brauche ich Fullscreen?
Sonst sehe ich nämlich nichts, gescheit.
So, also hier, das ist ein, da weiß ich nicht, ob man das ordentlich erkennt.
Wahrscheinlich sieht man das nicht.
Mini Forum.
Oh hier.
Mini Forum UM690 Mini PC.
32 GB RAM, 512 GB SSD.
Wir bauen gleich noch eine zweite SSD ein.
Und ein AMD Ryzen 9 6900HX.
Das bedeutet auch, da ist eine, das ist eine, wie heißt das Ding?
APU.
Und da ist eine Grafikkarte und alles mögliche mit drinne.
Grafikkarte, alles mögliche, Grafikkarte und CPU.
Also keine dedicated Grafikkarte, dafür ist es relativ klein.
So und als Controller probieren wir gleich den, ich habe noch, ich habe noch einen ganz alten ausgebuddelt.
Hier Leute, guckt mal, das seht ihr auch am Staub.
Ich habe noch einen alten Xbox 360 Controller ausgebuddelt.
Einen mit Kabel sogar, glücklicherweise.
Und da können wir noch einen PS4 Controller ausprobieren.
Und wir können noch einen Wireless, weiß ich, ob die Dinger Bluetooth sind.
Day One 2013 Xbox One Controller.
Leute, das kostet nicht 1000 Euro, das Ding kostet, ähm...
Zwischen, zwischen 550 und 850.
Amazon, Amazon ist jebait.
Amazon ist richtig dämlich.
Warte mal, ich zeige euch das mal.
Ihr müsst, also du kannst bei Amazon kaufen, dann ist es natürlich ein bisschen teurer.
Aber du kriegst, du kriegst es billiger.
Und zwar, guckt mal.
Amazon UM690.
So, der da.
Dann steht dann da 1000 Euro und dann müsst ihr hier unten drauf gehen.
Apply 150 Euro Voucher.
Und wenn ihr den Voucher applied habt, kostet es gleich nur noch 850 Euro.
Warum sie es nicht einfach ohne Voucher machen und das 850 kosten lassen, weiß ich nicht.
Es ist total hängen geblieben.
Das ist aber schon die, fast die Maximalausstattung.
Wenn du, wenn du ein bisschen warten kannst, Mini Forum Store.
Wenn du ein bisschen warten kannst, kriegst du es noch billiger.
Das ist, das ist hardcore jebait.
UM690.
Wenn du ein bisschen warten kannst, kriegst du es noch billiger.
Solltest du, also guck mal, du kriegst für 560 Euro.
Solltest du tatsächlich...
Ach, gucke mal.
In Germany gibt es, ach Moment, Barebone, Barebone.
Okay, jaja.
Also sprich, solltest du, solltest du warten können noch ein bisschen.
Dann kannst du dir die, die nackige Variante kaufen für 560 Euro.
Wenn du, also wenn du RAM hast und Zeug hast.
Ansonsten meine Kombination kostet hier, okay.
Ich habe 50 Euro mehr bei Amazon bezahlt.
Dafür, dass ich direkt habe.
Du kannst natürlich auch so eine Kombination machen.
Wobei ich ehrlich, ehrlich, ganz im Ernst.
Eventuell würde ich sogar auf Barebone gehen.
Und mir einen Low Profile RAM und eine SSD kaufen.
Was, wie viel?
Full?
Die Frage verstehe ich nicht.
Also für 500, also sagen wir mal so.
Das hier, das hier ist eigentlich eine gute, das ist eigentlich eine ganz gute Kombi.
16G RAM reicht für so ziemlich alles, 512G.
Das ist gar, das ist okay.
Es kommen noch Shipping Rates dabei.
Das geht, das geht durchaus.
Vielleicht kriegt man es auch mal bei irgendeinem Sale oder so ein bisschen billiger.
Also das passt, finde ich.
SSD habe ich auch noch rumliegen.
Wir bauen auch gleich noch eine zweite SSD ein.
Wir bauen gleich noch eine zweite SSD ein.
Und natürlich kann man da SSDs einbauen.
Genau, so, jetzt habe ich euch das gezahlt.
Also 850 Euro für die Ausstattung, die ich habe.
16GB ist fast ein bisschen wenig.
Na ja, ja, es ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt, ein bisschen mehr zu haben.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das Shared Memory ist.
Ehrlich gesagt, mit der GPU.
Da bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, ob das Shared Memory ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich bin mich nicht näher mit beschäftigt bisher.
Nein, nein, nein, das ist alles in einem.
850 Euro für CPU, GPU.
Das ist ja so eine Kombi-Kiste.
CPU, GPU, SSD und RAM.
Also du kannst das komplett eins zu eins betreiben.
Ich habe auch noch SSDs rumliegen.
Da haben sich wie in den letzten Jahren welche angesammelt.
So, also machen wir mal hier den Controller weg.
Gibt es denn einen Shortcut OBS in Fullscreen zu machen?
Projekto.
So, also das sind die Controller, die wir ausprobieren.
Dann habe ich hier wieder meinen Trusted, Trusted USB Stick,
wo da Kram draufkommt.
So, und jetzt packen wir das Teil mal schnell aus.
Kurz die Verpackung weg und dann schauen wir mal rein,
wie das so aussieht.
Ihr seht, es ist auch original verpackt.
Ich habe noch nichts gemacht.
Mal ganz in den Mülleimer pfeffern.
So, dann gucken wir mal.
Miniform.
Ich könnte das Bild drehen.
So, das probieren wir mal.
Wenn ich das Bild drehe,
das müssen wir mal checken, ob das funktioniert.
Weil dann seht ihr das in der richtigen,
aber dann sieht es halt ein bisschen schepp aus.
Mal ausprobieren kurz.
Wenn ich das Bild drehe, erst mal kurz hier.
Rotation.
Sieht man nichts mehr.
Jetzt ist es aber richtig rum.
Jetzt habe ich es richtig, richtig rum.
Rotated.
Das Problem ist jetzt, jetzt habe ich es halt.
Jetzt stimmt das Seitenverhältnis nicht.
16 zu 9, ich bräuchte 9 zu 16.
Das funktioniert so nicht.
Wir müssen uns von der Seite angucken.
Sonst müsste ich jetzt am Handy rumwursten.
Gut, also packen wir das Ding mal aus.
Gucken wir mal rein.
Alles klar.
China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Es riecht nach neuer Technik,
aber es stinkt nicht nach billigem China-Kram.
Es ist nicht so, dass du denkst,
du hast jetzt gleich irgendwelche Luftröhrenverätzungen,
wenn du das einatmen musst.
Also China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Es ist nicht empfohlen für die Customer,
den CPU-Cooler zu entfernen.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt auch nicht vor,
Wenn das Mainboard kaputt geht,
kann man das wegwerfen
oder gibt es einen Ersatz Mainboards?
Keine Ahnung, ich habe nicht vor,
das Mainboard kaputt zu machen.
Es ist ja auch nicht so,
dass es irgendwie so auf einmal,
ups, das Mainboard ist kaputt.
Also es ist meistens ja nicht so,
dass das Mainboard einfach so kaputt geht.
Weiß ich, wie oft euch schon mal
das Mainboard kaputt gegangen ist.
Aber wahrscheinlich kannst du es wegschmeißen,
wenn dir das Mainboard kaputt geht, ja.
So, das schmeiße ich mal auf die Erde,
das brauchen wir eh nicht.
So, in der Mitte, da ist er.
Das Ding ist wirklich klein hier, guck dir mal.
Wirklich kleine Kiste.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Verpackungskram.
Wir haben, was ist das?
Was ist das?
Ein SATA-Kabel?
Das sieht nicht aus wie ein SATA-Kabel.
Ah, ja jetzt erkennt man es.
Das ist ein SATA-Stromkabel.
Aber nur ein...
Nee, wait a minute.
Das ist ein SATA und ein SATA-Strom
in so einem Mini, Mini...
In so einem Mini-Kabel.
Das ist doch bestimmt nicht
standardkonform, oder?
Das ist doch bestimmt nicht standardkonform für SATA.
Schön mit Heißkleber zusammengepappt.
Ich will zusätzlich eine normale anbringen.
Ich will die SATA und eine normale SSD anbringen.
Okay, das brauchen wir auf jeden Fall gleich noch.
Dann haben wir ein Stromkabel.
Das brauche ich nicht,
da habe ich hier schon eins liegen.
Da daneben, man sieht es nicht,
aber da hinten, hier so, da liegt eins.
Dann haben wir einmal HDMI.
Das brauche ich auch nicht,
habe ich bei der Capture Card dabei,
aber vielleicht nehmen wir auch das.
Dann haben wir hier einen Stand,
ein paar Gummifüßchen,
eine Weserhalterung.
Das ist natürlich cool, dass sie dabei ist.
Die kann ich dann nämlich direkt
hinten am meinen Fernseher machen.
Das Ding, Weserhalterung
und ein Netzteil.
Das ist das was.
Und zwar ist das ein 19 Volt.
Okay, was ganz Scheppes.
19 Volt, 6,3 Ampere Netzteil.
Warum muss es ausgerechnet 19 Volt sein,
dass er dann gar nichts anderes
daran anschließen kann?
Okay, so der Weser-Mount,
den machen wir mal weg.
Den brauche ich jetzt gerade nicht.
Kommt hier in die Ecke.
Den Ständer brauche ich jetzt auch nicht.
Kommt hier auch in die Ecke.
So, packen wir mal aus.
Gucken wir mal.
Ist schön klein das Ding auf jeden Fall.
Fühlt sich gut an.
Fühlt sich Plastik an, ja.
Aber fühlt sich gut an.
Nur mal so Größenvergleich, Leute.
Xbox Controller oder Xbox 360
oder nehmen wir den anderen, der hat keinen Kabel.
So wie der Kerl das auch im Video gemacht.
Guck mal.
Also das Ding ist klein.
Das ist ein bisschen kürzer.
Der Xbox Controller ist ein bisschen länger.
Dafür ist das Ding oben und unten ein bisschen breiter.
Also es ist relativ klein.
Guck mal.
Also er hat ziemlich genau
die Abmaße von einem Xbox Controller.
Das ist ziemlich, ziemlich kurz.
Was heißt Staubschicht?
Was meinst du, wie oft du den Xbox Controller verwendest?
So, was haben wir denn am Start?
Ein Mini-Forum.
Minis-Forum.
Anschlüsse.
Was gibt es da Schönes?
Oh, guck mal.
2,5G Netzwerk.
Nicht, dass man es da brauchen würde,
aber besser als nichts.
2,5G Netzwerk.
Dann haben wir viermal USB,
zweimal HDMI
und den Stromanschluss.
Und hier irgendwas zum
zum Festschließen,
wenn ich da heimlich brauchen.
lude
Meine Chat wieder!
Das ist ja wieder geil!
So witzig!
Mein Chat!
Ich bin ein bisschen enttäuscht von ihm. Er bastelt und wundert sich schon über zwei Sachen. Oh nein, ich packe eine neue Kiste aus und wundere mich über Sachen.
Das ist ja aber unerhört, Alter.
Unerhört, da wundert er sich einfach, Mann. Anzeige ist raus.
Five fat time, aber richtig. Also manchmal habe ich echt keinen Plan, was die Leute dazu verleitet, so ein Blödsinn zu schreiben.
Was? Weiß jemand, ob die Ask Chat GPT CLI Tools irgendwo zum Download gibt? Ja klar gibt es das.
Das erste nennt sich Chat GPT Rapper. Kannste eins zu eins auf GitHub suchen. Und das andere nennt sich...
Äh, wie hieß das andere? CLI Tool. Ich warte mal, ich sags dir.
Das andere heißt AI Ask, glaube ich. AI Ask GitHub. AI CLI heißt das andere.
Ich erinnere mich dran, wenn ich zurück auf den Linux Desktop schalte, zeige ich dir.
Wofür planst du denn diesen Minicomputer einzusetzen? Es steht legit eins zu eins im Titel. Wir bauen eine Emulator Kiste, die ich dann hinten an meinem Fernseher hänge.
Mit Barthosera Linux drauf. Ich habe auch schon ein paar höchst selbst gerippte Roms zum ausprobieren später. Und dann kommt hier hinten bei mir ein Fernseher. Das Gute ist, dass eine Weserhalterung dabei ist. Hinten ein Fernseher mit einem Controller und dann werde ich ein bisschen...
Das Ding kann angeblich bis rauf zu Switch emulieren. Richtig gut. Wo ist er preislich? Also wenn du es im Original Shop kaufst, geht es bei 550 Euro los. Ohne RAM und ohne CPU. Äh, nicht ohne CPU, Schwachsinn. Ohne RAM und ohne SSD.
CPU ist drinne. Das ist die 32G RAM, 512G SSD Variante. Die kostet im Shop 800 Euro und bei Amazon 850 Euro. Am einfachsten ist wahrscheinlich, wenn man sich selbst so ein Low Profile RAM und M2 SSD kauft, wahrscheinlich die kleine Variante, aber so viel teurer ist es nicht.
Der Erde hat 2,5G. Ich meine nicht, dass man es brauchen würde. Es ist aber ganz praktisch, wenn man über Samba beispielsweise, nur selbst erstellte, selbst gerippte Isos natürlich rüber kopieren will.
Oder die gesamte NES, äh die gesamte N64 Collection mit 350 Games. Die ist auch glaube nur irgendwie, weiß ich natürlich nicht wie groß die ist, aber die ist auch nicht so groß. So, also gucken wir mal. Wo geht das auf? Was haben wir hier? Einmal Lüfter.
Das ist Metallgitter, das finde ich schon mal ganz gut. Seriennummer. Was ist das? H1-2-CAM? Ist auch ein bisschen doofes Seriennummer, aber gut. So, dann machen wir das mal auf, weil ich will ja noch eine SSD. Wo habe ich meine SSD überhaupt? Wo habe ich die hin? Wahrscheinlich im Schrank noch.
Ich will noch eine SSD rein machen. Ich glaube die Schrauben sind hier drunter irgendwo.
Oh das ist natürlich doof hier, das kriegt man ja kaum ab. Das ist blöd. Deswegen sind da auch, guckt mal Leute, deswegen sind da auch noch extra Füßchen dabei. Falls man die abreißt.
Was haben wir für Event-Infra? Was ist das denn? Ist das ein Tool oder meinst du irgendwie sowas wie irgendwelche Message-Bus-Sachen? Event-Infra sagt mir gar nichts.
Ich brauche was als Steam-Cache. Also das Ding hat einen 2-Slot und hat auf jeden Fall ordentlich Dampf. Aber ich glaube du brauchst die Grafik-Power von dem Ding gar nicht.
Front I.O. ist, das ist wahrscheinlich die Strom-An-Strom-Aus-Anzeige oder so. Mikrofon oder Lautsprecher? Mikrofon, USB, USB 4, ganz bestimmt.
Wir wissen genau, dass die korrekte Bezeichnung nicht USB 4 ist, sondern USB 4.2 Gen 3x2 C1.X IEEE I5 AC. Obviously. Das sind ja Noobs, die denken einfach es heißt USB 4.
So. Und wir haben noch einen Super-Speed 10 Gigabit. Ok. Alles klar. Ok. Mal gucken, dass wir das jetzt aufkriegen ohne es komplett kaputt. Oh, das geht aber wirklich schwierig ab.
Ok. Ich glaube das ist nach einmal abziehen. RIP. Aber wir haben ja, wir haben ja, wobei, es geht. Es geht. Aber wir haben ja Ersatz, Ersatz-Pads. Oh, ich dachte da sind die, ja doch da sind die Schrauben drunter. Hier ist eine Schraube drunter.
Das ist natürlich doof gemacht, dass man hier unten drunter mit an die Schraube dran kommt. Guck mal, hier ist die Schraube drunter. Das ist, das ist schon ziemlich Pilpega. Weil wenn, also das kannst du mit dem Ding, das kannst du, das kannst du 3-4 Mal machen, dann ist das Teil im Arsch.
Mit dem Füllen den Kleber erwärmen. Exzellent. Aber das ist Gummi. Ich weiß nicht was da zuerst Probleme macht. Gummi oder der Kleber.
Schraube einfach nicht mehr einbauen. Jetzt für den Stream werde ich es eh offen lassen. Jetzt gucken wir mal, vielleicht, vielleicht wenn man da mit dem Schraubendreher drunter geht, geht es einfacher ab.
Ne, nimmt sich, nimmt sich nichts. Ach, der geht besser ab. Guck mal, der geht wirklich, der geht besser ab. Ah, man muss das mit dem Plastik unten drunter abreißen. Man muss da einmal richtig drunter greifen, dann geht es auch besser.
Jetzt habe ich, guck, hier ist jetzt gar kein Plastik-Shit drauf, hier ist noch Plastik-Shit drauf. Ok, mal gucken ob meiner, ob das hier passt.
Nope, gucken ob der passt. Wo habe ich denn meinen Schraub-Schrauber? Schraubi-Schrauber? Wo ist denn mein kleiner, kleiner Schraubendreher hin? Der ganz kleine, nicht der?
Ah, manchmal finde ich meinen Scheiß nicht. Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich an der Werkzeugwand. Ok, das funktioniert nicht. Hier komme ich nicht mit rein. Ich, ich hole mal kurz, ich hole mal kurz. Was? Wir brauchen da drin bestimmt noch mehr Schrauben.
So. Wie blöd. Na, ein paar Mal klebt das schon noch. Ein paar Mal klebt das noch, aber ich glaube drei bis vier Mal, dann ist, dann ist vorbei. Ja, jetzt geht das. Hallo? Alter, das ist aber ganz schön fest, man.
Ok, ich glaube ich muss mal wirklich was anderes holen, so kommt man da nicht gescheit dran.
Gerade mal wieder aufräumen. Ich hole mal, ich hole mal was ordentliches.
Oh, jetzt habe ich ein bisschen zu sehr das Ding hier auf den Tisch gehauen.
So, packen wir mal aus. So, das Ding könnten wir wahrscheinlich gleich gebrauchen zum abmachen.
Und eventuell so ein Teil. Ich brauche mal was zum ablegen, was mir Kai, was mich im Stream ein bisschen Platz hat.
So, dann gucken wir mal, was braucht man da für irgendwas kleines? Das da? Ja, das funktioniert gut.
Gut. So, das muss ich mal kurz hier rausnehmen, weil die Dinger sind aus irgendwelchen Gründen ziemlich, ziemlich fest, aber jetzt, jetzt geht's.
Tak, deswegen mag ich übrigens dieses Silikon, das, warum ist denn da was blaues noch dran? Guck mal, war irgendwie rein Silikon oder so.
Ja, ich spiegele mich hier laufend.
Jetzt ist der Plastik-Scheiß darüber und die Schraube kommt nicht raus, Mann.
So, das ist der Plastik-Scheiß.
Das ist der Plastik-Scheiß.
unten hat. Was da für ne m2 ssd drin ist, vielleicht können wir das ab, also wenn wir
glück haben, können wir das von unten sehen. ich würde ungern den passivkühler abmachen.
ok wer ist high iq und findet raus was das für ne ssd ist. wer kriegt das raus. wd blue
weil das ding blue ist. Kingston woher weißt du das. woher. das redest du jetzt einfach
oder. ok jetzt hat jeder mal irgendwas gesagt. wir gucken jetzt einfach nach was das für
ne ssd ist. jetzt einfach nach was das für ne ssd ist. erstmal geben wir das von da
unten ein 2 0 7 2. 2 0 2 7 5 2 3. dazu findet man gar nix und das da oben ist e 18 7 5 6
5. alles klar. 2 2 5 5. 2 2 2 5. 9 2 1. ne dazu findet man ja mal gar nix.
ok keine ahnung was das für eine ist. ist mir auch egal. ich mach jetzt den passivkühler
auf jeden fall nicht ab. vielleicht findet man was zu 9 4 v-0. ne das ist das pcb. google
sag Kingston nach was hast du gegoogelt. ne ich mach den kühler nicht runter. kühler
nicht runter. also ssd keine ahnung was das für eine ist. werden wir gleich auskriegen.
so wir haben 2 mal ram drinne. Kingston ram auf jeden fall. ich mein wenn die Kingston
ram drinne haben. wärs vielleicht auch ne Kingston ssd. aber keine ahnung. mann mann
weiß das nicht. scroll mal hoch wurde schon verlinkt. ja tatsächlich. die farbe bei
passt schon mal. also die farbe passt gut. aber von den nummern her ist es halt nix sagend.
aber gut wahrscheinlich ist es die. wahrscheinlich ist es die. 2 bild ist von der rückseite.
ja doch. doch das wird die wahrscheinlich sein. ja ja das ist die. die nummer ein bisschen
variieren kann schon sein. das ist die. ich gehe schon mal stark von aus dass die das
ist. die können es nachher auslesen. das stimmt. ok. also iphone kamera. gut also haben wir
das hier. dann ist das hier einmal wlan würde ich sagen. ja einmal wlan. dann haben wir
das. und zwar was für ram haben wir. Kingston ram. steht da irgendwas interessantes drauf.
es müssen 2 mal 16g sein. erkenne ich aber jetzt nicht. ach da oben hier 16. DDR4 wahrscheinlich
hier. DDR4 gehe ich jetzt mal einfach von aus. ich glaube das stand da auch dabei.
so wie kriegt man da jetzt eine ssd rein angibt. ach hier unten. guck mal hier unten kommt
die ssd rein. muss ich das ausbauen um die ssd einzubauen. dazu gucken wir jetzt tatsächlich
doch mal ins handbuch. ob da was zu drinnen steht. also china chinesen handbuch. bla bla
bla. air vents. anschlüsse. anschlüsse. aufschrauben. do it yourself ssd. gut das
ist für die m2 ssd. ach ne hier oben kommt die ssd rein. nicht unten drunter. guck mal
die ssd kommt hier oben drauf. do it yourself hdd. führen sie die beiden befestigungslöcher
an der seite der 2,5 zoll hdd festplatte in die schnallen der festplattenhalterung
ein. ja alles klar. jetzt ist nur die frage wie man das anschließt. ah guck mal da. das
da. schaut mal hier das da oben. das da oben da kommt das wohl rein. hier. hier da.
ich glaube so rum. alter das ist ja mal beschissen ey. das ist ja mal mega beschissen. wie soll
man das dann rein kriegen? da haben sie sich was ausgedacht die china chinesen man. was
ist das? gleich hab ich's geprägt. ok ich hab's. ok das ist genau für einmal reinstecken
gemacht hier. einmal reinstecken und nie wieder raus machen. ok das ist der sata kram. dann
hole ich mal kurz die ssd. ich müsste. guck mal. mit data oder so. ok. ok. ok. ok. ok.
ja. so pass mal auf. ähm. ok. ok. ok. ok. ok. ok. ok. ok. ok. ok. ok. ok. ok. ok. ok.
Ich habe ich habe was gefunden ich hätte gar nicht gedacht dass ich das ich so was
am start habe
und zwar das machen wir nicht ich sage es euch gleich guckt mal was ich noch gefunden
habe mit 2,5 zoll festplatte die soll da rein da habe ich meine zweifel dass das
passen würde die machen wir da ich sage ich sage gleich dass man die machen wir
da nicht rein aber die die würde doch im leben im leben würde ich doch hier keine
2,5 zoll festplatte mehr reinkriegen guck mal die festplatte ist die festplatte
ist größer als das gesamte gehäuse echt ist es in 3,5 zoll
ihr habt recht es ist 3,5 zoll die ist bloß einfach ein bisschen kleiner die ist bloß
nicht so hoch die ist die ist einfach nur kleiner okay na gut dann habe ich doch
keine 2,5 zoll aber ich habe eine ssd und die kommt da rein und die ssd muss ich
vorher hier guck mal hier das sind die das sind die löcher wo man das einführen
soll gatchi bass so funktioniert das easy guck mal da kannst du gar nichts
großartig verkehrt machen und jetzt und jetzt kann sie neben fest schrauben
mehr das ist ja easy das ganze da machst du da machst du wirklich nichts verkehrt
da kannst du da kannst du wirklich nichts verkehrt machen
wir müssen die ssd aber vorher noch mal kurz wippen weil es könnte sein dass
dort noch irgendwas bootbares drauf ist bin mir nicht ganz sicher was da drauf
sein könnte deswegen will ich zumindest mal mbr die den das ist nicht das ist
gefällig wobei wir buten eh von usb also ist das eigentlich auch egal egal ich
die diesmal schnell ich muss nur mal kurz gucken ob ich hier nicht ob ich
irgendwo so ein adapter hier noch habe also ich habe welche ich weiß bloß
nicht wo 2,5 zoll nicht 2,5 zoll doch 2,5 also ssd sata ssd auf usb
irgendwo hier habe ich sowas weiß bloß nicht wo
hier ist es nicht wo könnte ich denn sowas haben
jede menge usb sticks nice usb sticks kartenleser aber kein blöd
wo habe ich irgendwo einen adapter ich muss noch mal kurz an schrank ich muss
noch mal kurz an schrank gucken ob ich den usb oder vielleicht hier unter
unterm tisch bei irgendeiner ablage hier weil wenn wir basteln brauchen wir so
dinge öfters mal
er sieht nicht so aus
nicht so aus als wäre hier was drin raspberry pi brauchen wir jetzt ganz
bestimmt nicht in sp 32 brauchen wir jetzt auch nicht ok ich muss mal kurz an
schrank ich habe ich habe auf jeden fall noch welche keine m2 doch guck mal m2
beides kommt eine m2 rein und so eine weil ich noch übrig habe ich mein besser als
dass der kram bei mir im schrank vergammelt oder
sicher erase geht schneller
ich muss da nicht sicher erheben ich will ja nur dass das ding direkt von usb
boot und nicht von der eingebauten platte und damit ich das löschen kann muss ich
irgendwie anschließen ich komme mal kurz in schrank ich habe
siehst du haben wir doch zack
dann schließe ich das mal kurz bei mir einen rechner an format hier das eine
runde an der vm dürft ihr mir sogar zugucken
zack ach ja weil irgendjemand eine frage hatte wie die tools hießen also einmal
ist das hier ai cli das ist für github code code pilot in der shell und das
andere ist chat gpt rapper das hier das sind die zwei tools die ich euch gerade
gezeigt habe
chat habt ihr wieder habt ihr wieder haarresse erkannt der chat erkennt wieder
heute harrisse im mainboard ich sehe schon kommen das letzte mal war auch
schlimm man harrisse im mainboard ich weiß doch ich habe meinen rechner auf
die seite gelegt da kamen die leute max du kannst ein rechner noch nicht auf die
seite legen harrisse im mainboard nice ppega also connect zur vm excellent noch
lachst du ja ich bin nämlich auf dem pc auf dem pc wo ich die harrisse angeblich
hatte der ist noch nicht einmal abgestürzt fdisk minus l def sdb was
haben wir da 465 ja das ist tatsächlich richtig gegen das noch mal hd paar wie
ist das nicht drauf zum auslesen hd palm def sdb jaja ist gut
nee was ist das hd palm minus v ach kacke ich kann man noch mal hersteller
und gedöns auslesen lassen wenn nur und so weiter
habe info was mit 8 minus l war es missing door
das ging mit hd ging das mit hd palm nicht auch info
ich weiß ich weiß was es für der ssd ist hw info ok
aber info auch gut erstmal hw info def sdb
ok was ach minus klein l ne chat ihr habt genauso wenig ahnung wie ich
es kann auch sein dass es mit dem usb adapter gar nicht funktioniert
ah exquisite sdb die weiß model siste linux linux beste model wenn nur
deshalb ok das ist das ist von dem usb von dem usb adapter
alles gleich wieder weg also gut dann
hw info minus minus disk geht nicht ich habe ich habe es jetzt schon wieder ok
komm wir probieren es jetzt noch mal aus hw info minus minus und jetzt def sdb
ok also was ist es denn es ist moment ach das sind alle discs jetzt oder wie
das sind alle alle des ok das hier oben ist das interessante das da sieht man
nix dazu z ram usb jcron mikro ja das ist es das ist die das ist die ja das
ist die so mikron
ne das ist die das ist der usb adapter ach scheiß drauf ich war sdb ist auf
jeden fall die richtige so jetzt kommen wir fragen mal chat chat chat gpt how to
how to clear mbr on linux for off of ssd how to clear ssd
so clear mbr ja auf chat gpt gibt gas mann ich meine ich weiß wie es geht ich
will wissen was chat gpt macht du machst einfach die ersten was einfach die
ersten 4 4 also normalerweise 512 mb aber du machst mal die ersten 4 mb einfach
mit nullen und gut ist ok dd if def 0 of def sdx ja ok bs 446 count minus 1 ok
das ist gar nicht so schlecht das ist gar nicht so schlecht wir machen sdb und
machen allerdings block size 4 m zack und jetzt ist jetzt ist alles gut
schauen wir mal was der erkannt hat def sdb ist gar nichts drauf na und fdisk
ist auch der meinung da tut sich nix ne da ist da ist gar nichts
gut mkfs mkfs x4 def also ich kann halt schreiben def sdb und machen neues
fallsystem und dann hängen was in die kiste rein gut jetzt haben wir das ding
gelöscht also gelöscht gelöscht haben wir es nicht wirklich aber wir haben es
jetzt so gemacht dass es so aussieht als wäre es leer wenn die ssd
beziehungsweise adapter drinnen können kannst du noch mit blk disk art schnell
alter der chat ist blk disk art chat ist heute wieder high IQ blk disk disk art
minus f def sdb operation zu port nope kann es nicht egal weg damit zack so
capture kart wieder anschließen an dem port bei capture kart können wir gleich
anschließen weil dann muss ich das muss ich muss
es eh bewegen
connect to host
capture kann es wieder krägt mal gucken ob die capture kart funktioniert
jepp nice du alles klar switchen wir mal auf die kamera und bauen die ssd ein
account macht das nur für einen block korrekt also block size 4m sind 4006
9 spite und das ganze nur einmal wenn du das account weglässt macht das für das
ganze device gut also jetzt sollen wir was machen
also am besten ist macht es einen unterschied wie rum der deckel drauf
kommt
glaube ich ist glaube ich relativ egal wie wir den deckel drauf machen also
muss man kurz überlegen die
warte mal wie rum wie rum muss ich muss gucken dass ich es richtig rum rein
mache also so okay und jetzt ja ich würde sagen das muss dann so rein also
sprich im prinzip
so
oder nicht
doch so easy gucken dass es dran ist hier unten ist auch alles drin so jetzt
machen wir die ssd wieder rein
nein das ist ein mini forum leute falls ich irgendwas über sehe ich bin hier
gerade am basteln kann ich gucke nur ab und zu mal auf den chat
du müsst jetzt muss er jetzt noch mal schreiben
also das ist ein mini ford das ist kein nuke das ist ein mini forum um 690
oh leute ich habe meine anti statik armband vergessen jetzt ist jetzt ist
alles verloren jetzt ist vorbei jetzt neuen pc kaufen
ich meine ich hätte sogar eins ja das glaube an diesem i fix it ist eins dabei
ja könnte man könnte man also wir machen wir machen es nicht so wie wie hieß
wie ist diese youtube seite noch mal die dann einfach gesagt hat so jetzt haben
wir unser anti statik armband an und alles ist gut also man muss das
irgendwo dran machen am besten irgendwie so an die an die heizung hier
unten aber scheiß drauf ganz im ernst wörts war das genau mal hier wieder rein
gut alles gut passt sitzt fast war gelohnt luft hätte meine oma jetzt
gesagt dazu
ok gut
also ganz so richtig so richtig gut passen tut tut es irgendwie nicht aber
habe ich ich muss mal gucken nicht dass ich jetzt irgendwie blöd blöd dran
machen das ist doch die und die orientierung spielt doch eine rolle kann
ja sein nicht dass nie weil wir jetzt noch mal noch mal abmachen wer blöder
ne die orientierung spielt echt keine rolle das ist exakt symmetrisch unten
hi max kenne dich seit fünf jahren nur von über jetzt habe ich dich bei twitch entdeckt
mach weiter so feier deine wiese schön dass du den weg hier gefunden hast
also es macht auch überhaupt keinen unterschied wie wir ran nicht mal so kann
ich es nicht machen so kann ich es nicht mein ich kann es jetzt nur noch so rum machen aber
so wirklich gut passen doch passt so ein ist so eigentlich alles in ordnung
ok passt so richtig zufrieden bin ich mit dem sitz mit dem sitz nicht
wir müssen das gerade mal ich mache ich mache das gerade noch mal ab das kabel vielleicht ist es
doch nicht egal wie rum wie rum das drauf kommt vielleicht ist es doch nicht egal aber noch mal
kurz ab ich das irgendwie aber pass auf dass das kackt mir das geht mir jetzt kaputt wenn ich
es abmache ok vergiss es geht gar nicht mehr ab doch geht geht noch ab ohne dass ich es abreiße
mal kurz gucken also so passt so passt besser wobei ich glaube das ist einfach schon von
anfang an nicht so hundertprozentig moment das ist doch nicht symmetrischt aha wartet mal
ok so ist ich glaube so muss es so muss es so muss er alles gut ok so muss das ding weil
hier vorne ist es flach und hier ist es sonst nirgendwo flach alles klar ok das das ergibt was
sind das dahinten das ergibt sinne ich hätte mir vielleicht mal merken sollen wie ich das wie
ich den kram auf und zu gemacht habe ich glaube das ist wlan das ist wlan und bluetooth hier auf
diesem ding ok dann machen wir es gerade mal wieder dran ok ssd ist dran theoretisch könnte
man die ssd wahrscheinlich einfach irgendwie so reinlegen oder so aber das machen wir nicht
so zu machen müssen wir eindeutig so rum es geht ja nur in eine richtung
der sound ist vorbei
was hatten wir eben für ein sound
schnell im wort nachschauen feifett idee wir haben doch das wort wo blots twitch wir gucken
jetzt im stream nach wie rum ich es aufgemacht habe macht habe chat ist wieder sehr schlau heute
so also gucken wir mal ok
ok wie rum wie rum habe ich es aufgemacht mal gucken ob man das irgendwie erkennt wo
ist vorne wo ist vorne hier ist der einschalter und hier ist hier ist das gitter hier ist dieses
wo ist denn was ich erkenne das anrecht wo ist der aufkleber der aufkleber ist der aufkleber
ist da ok das ist das ist das ist die seite wo das modellding drinne steht achte auf die
seite mit dem klebestreifen genau genau so ok dass ich sehe es ja eigentlich schon die
ecke ok hier ist hier ist das mit dem streifen hier ist das mit dem streifen moment so und
der kleber ist da oben ok leute ich hat es richtig ich habe ich habe es richtig rekonstruiert
alles klar ich weiß wie rum ich weiß wie rum es kommt mit dem ja der kleber ist unten
an dem ok alles klar also so rum kommt guck so exakt so hatten wir es also hier unten
hier unten ist das ding mit dem hier unten ist das teil mit dem man sieht es nicht richtig
hier ist das das ding mit dem seriennummer teil oder passt das ok also dann muss die
ssd jetzt hier irgendwie rein ne warte mal muss es ja im endeffekt
sollte ich die ssd noch festschrauben ich meine wer könnte die ssd noch festschrauben
das problem ist ich brauche eine schraube dafür ich habe doch habe ich hier irgendwie
eine lasst mal kurz lasst mal kurz checken immer festschrauben nicht so als mal gucken
ob das passt bin mir nicht sicher ich habe jetzt irgendeine genommen die hier lag ok
scheint zu passen holgers guck mal first try richtige schraube gefunden oh shit man das
ist ja 3d chess alter dass du hier das ding eingebaut kriegst es gibt wieder haarisse
im mainboard ja ok also so so rum so rum muss das ding so rum muss das rein
ok alles klar jetzt passts jetzt passts jetzt kommt die schraube noch hier rein
ein bisschen drauf drücken muss dass es funktioniert
gut excellent alles setzt alles passt das kommt auch hier rein und zu gut zack
ja alles klar es passt auch so schrauben nein ich werde jetzt nicht so festschrauben
einfach mal ein bisschen also ich so dass ich sie wieder ab krieg falls ich noch mal
aus irgendwelchen aus irgendwelchen gründen aufmachen muss
wo ist die schraube hin
ach da die sehe ich von hier nicht ihr seht die ich stehe ja hier die sieht man nicht
gescheit nä man sieht das man sieht das nicht gescheit von hier
alter was hier mit der musik los
also ich verlasse mich einfach mal drauf dass ich alles richtig gemacht habe noch noch
pappense die das no he lacks critical information wahrscheinlich nicht alles richtig gemacht
ok passt so zu ist fertig alles eingebaut excellent können wir anschalten auf gehts
weiter netzteil netzteil
ach so wir müssen ja noch eine linux usb stick machen aber erstmal booten und gucken
ob die capture card funktioniert zack zack und einmal strom wollt ihr wissen was das
ding für den stromverbrauch hat soll ich mal anschließen hier ich habe so ein teil
da dran können wir gucken was das für den stromverbrauch hat also ich habe ja ah nee
ihr seht ja noch ich habe hier dieses teil gucken kann als das hier rein passt während
das andere drin steckt ja gerade so gerade so ich glaube wenn ich sie so hinschiebe dann
seht ihr es ja erstmal anschließen vorher capture card capture card connecten die machen
wir hinter dem hinterm stuhl lang dass ich nicht drüber fallen ich kenne mich bei sowas
muss da nämlich vorne rum gleich die tastatur und so vielleicht dran stöpseln hdmi oder
hdmi wie das die coolen leute nennen was kostet das ding zwischen 550 euro und 850 euro
das ist nicht die billigste kiste aber du kannst dann alles emulieren bis rauf zur
switch bis ihr kurzes kabel ich nehme doch ein anderes hdmi ich nehme doch ein anderes
hdmi kabel bis sie bis sie länger das ist das was dabei ist bei der capture card ich
habe noch richtig lange hdmi kabel da muss ich aber einen schrank aufmachen und mal gucken
ich habe ja mal hier letzter zeit an weihnachten rum aufgeräumt und ich habe jetzt alles soweit
sortiert dass ich den kram relativ schnell finde 15 watt eidl ja mal gucken ich weiß
es nicht probieren wir mal aus alter geh auf so schon besser es dürfte jetzt ungefähr
so eineinhalb meter hdmi kabel sein damit damit kommt man klar hdmi out hdmi in zack
alles gut dann schalten wir mal um schalten wir mal um auf elgato stellts no signal gucken
wir mal das ist primäre ich habe diese capture karte noch nie benutzt du kannst auch stream
deck os auf dem ding nutzen okay na will ich ja nicht also das ist das erste mal dass
ich diese capture karte verwende gucken ob die funktioniert primäre an ist ich drücke
jetzt den powerknopf es geht an macht ein bisschen geräusche und jetzt hoffe ich dass
ich gleich was sehe oder auch nicht sollte sollte aber auch hat sich gerade was getan
ne peak elgato
es ist gar nicht so schlecht eigentlich wenn man eine windows lizenz sogar mitbekommt
okay für flaschen mark schnellen usb stick clear connect to stream ist egal es weiß
wenn sich aktivieren lässt dann aber wahrscheinlich schon okay was haben wir hier schönes zu
bieten das ist wieder sdb für der sdb habe ich noch noch mal wieder sdb da haben wir
jetzt sogar zwei zwei sachen drauf ich glaube ich habe sogar gestern schon mal testweise
darauf geflasht also wir machen sie jetzt aber trotzdem noch mal okay wir verwenden
übrigens nicht etscher sondern wir verwenden usb image ich habe mir das aber gealliast
auf etscher weil ich sonst immer wahrscheinlich vergesse wie das tool heißt right please
select a writable source ach hier download barthosiera image ja zahn disc 120g kommt
hin verify gib ihm volle pulle alter right vorher entpacken nope ah ich bin nicht in
der usb gruppe okay aber das geht mein alias nicht was natürlich bescheuert so zack
boah alter der what the fuck der flutscht alter der flutscht der usb stick man der sync
wird das ding schon von hatten wird das ding schon mitmachen oder würde mich wundern der
usb stick ist erstmal 80 grad heiß das ging aber richtig zackig gerade nice flashtool
liegt aber eher am usb stick verify der jetzt oder was macht er oder ist er ist er ist
er fertig an der ist fertig komplett inklusive verify ist er dann alter der ist aber mal richtig
schnell mal gucken ob es funktioniert ja wir können der der form halber noch ein sink hinterher
schmeißen okay mal gucken ob das sich jetzt das ding mounten lässt mount def sdb tja gute
frage sdb 2 mount def sdb auf okay ich versuche einfach mal davon zu booten ich glaube dem
einfach mal dass er schon geflasht hat wir schieben es jetzt einfach mal rein und ich
starte das easy gucken wir mal nope elgato hello welcome windows gehen wir nicht auf
den sack usb stick dran usb stick dran und das ding wird neu gestartet und ich hoffe
dass es beim neustarten jetzt ordentlich ordentlich booted weil ich weiß nicht was ich für knopf
drücken muss und vom usb stick zu booten no signal nice gg eats warum hat das beim booten
eigentlich kein signal
direkt am monitor anscheinend das muss das ding schon können das muss es das muss es
schon checken moment habe ich jetzt ausgeschaltet oder was
es ist noch an man da irgendwas einstellen oder so
also muss man keine auflösung einstellen kann man also man kann custom resolution machen
aber nicht dass es ich kann runter bis auf 640 mal 480 no signal soll ich vielleicht
mal doch game capture game capture installieren elgato game capture ich hätte ich hätte
es funktioniert einfach erinnerst du dich an slow boot times ja das kann durchaus sein
es kann durchaus sein dass es slow slow boot times hat aber so slow boot times also man
sollte ja zumindest irgendwas sehen drauf anderen hdmi port können wir tatsächlich
mal probieren aber wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich vollkommen egal no signal gibt es nicht wir
wissen ja dass es im prinzip funktioniert weil wir haben es ja wir haben es ja eben
in windows schon mal gesehen ok ich installiere doch mal game capture wer weiß vielleicht
download game capture select your product capture was ist das hd 60 x glaube ich windows
ist das ding nicht früher mal game capture die alte gibt es gar nicht mehr zur auswahl
oder elgato game capture software die gibt es jetzt 4k capture 4k capture utility ok das
ding macht nichts ok dann installieren wir uns das 4k game capture utility jetzt help
nein nein nein kann ich das kann ich das nicht ohne admin rechte ach komm scheiß drauf
aber mit rechte pass auf jetzt wieder rieb jetzt wieder neu starten gleich game capture
elgato 4k capture utility heißt es jetzt dass jetzt neu anscheinend no signal ok geil capture
1080p nee nee nee nee device ähm was was willst du von mir
stream link beta hat aber früher konnte man doch die auflöser noch irgendwie umstellen
oder bin ich da jetzt zu pepega für no signal das ding sieht auf jeden fall anders aus als
früher es gibt aber mein game capture gibt es auch noch was zum gab warum gibt es da
schon wieder 1000 verschiedene software dafür es gibt das 4k capture utility und es gibt
game capture aber letztendlich ist es egal dass wir den game das wir den game capture
genauso wie nicht funktionieren no signal ich weiß was ich stöpsel einfach mal ab und
wieder dran wir wissen wir wissen ja im prinzip my great capture genauso hieß diese elgato
krempel immer my great game erstmal 4k capture erstmal alles erstmal alles löschen wieder
so also wir wissen ja dass es im prinzip funktioniert
ich ziehe noch mal ich ziehe einfach noch mal strom ab wir müssen jetzt mal kurz googlen
kann man mit so einer kammer mit der elgato karte überhaupt ins bios unterstützt die
das denn überhaupt hd wie heißt das ding hd 60 x bios
solution sollte eigentlich doch gehen wir werden bescheuern wenn das net klappt haben
wir vielleicht irgendwie mal so speck speck oder so davon hd 60 x speck so hd 60 technical
specifications capture resolutions sehr aussage kräftig abtue 480 p ich habe keine ahnung
welche auflösung normalerweise so ein bios hat
hd 60 ja oder wie viel oder das regt mir schon wieder oft dass ich ich weiß jetzt nicht
how do i capture bios also ich wir können auch die andere capture karte ich habe ja
noch ich habe ja noch die alte capture karte also mit der gehts auf jeden fall so ich mache
jetzt ich mache jetzt wieder an mal gucken ob jetzt ob jetzt was passiert ich ich okay
jetzt gehts einfach oder wie auch okay no signal die wissen echt nicht was da ist so
ich brauche mal ne maus ich brauche mal ne maus wo ist die maus alter maus please die
steckt unter dem tisch man krieg ich jetzt meine maus hier raus ich hab beim ja ja windows
ist gut ich brauch die zweite maus die steckt am anderen rechner dran und das dumme ist
irgendwie habe ich den rechner da drauf gestellt einfach mal hoch gehoben geht so windows will
ich da drauf definitiv nicht installieren deswegen mache ich jetzt ne maus dran repute
das ding und steckt den usb stick dran vielleicht muss ich auch die tastatur dran stöpseln
okay okay es ist wirklich relativ relativ lag lag free ich schau mal ob ich euch umschalten
kann das ihr wieder hier ordentlich was seht drinne no signal keckel okay die anzeigen
leute die anzeige die anzeige in obs sagt einfach oder man kann nicht beides offen haben
das kann auch sein das was wir machen hier einfach fullscreen und gut ist minis forum
das ist der 60 um 60 90 wie startet man hier übrigens neu make your computer easier to
use make your computer easy er hat das windows setup kein reboot button mehr oder wie
ich hab keine tastatur angeschlossen ich hab eigentlich gehofft man kann das alles
mit einem controller machen wenn ich das vom usb stick gebootet bekomme ansonsten muss
ich jetzt die tastatur hier rüber ich brauche mal ich brauche ein zweites set an tastatur
und maus ich bräuchte so eine mini mini tastatur mini maus für solche sachen dass ich immer
meine tastatur umstöpseln muss weil das das fakt schon ein bisschen ab ich stöpsel jetzt
die tastatur um man was willst du machen so tastatur die tastatur ist dran kann ich einfach
control alt entfernen drücken ne das geht natürlich nett aber das wäre auch zu einfach
schiff 10 moment man kann seriously man kann das setup nur noch rebooten über ne wie
macht man das shutdown ich ich bin zu dumm will noch setup zu rebooten all der vier ne
bin noch setup möchte nicht rebooted werden gibt es nicht
ein langes control alt entfernen ok nicht wirklich shut down minus slash ja yes ok
so und jetzt usb stick dran
muss irgendwann kann ich einen knopf drücken fürs bios und jetzt startet wieder wind aus
oder ich hemmere ich hemmere gleich entfernen ok nochmal neustand
wind aus nerf mich please nicht bei der gelegenheit ich kann jetzt noch nicht mal ich habe jetzt
nicht mal eine tastatur wo ich suchen kann und ich habe kein handy um um was einzutippen
wir testen jetzt wir testen jetzt alles durch ok wien aus was was war das schiff f10 shutdown
r t 0 ok entfernen entfernen entfernen entfernen meistens entfernen f2 f1
oder ein bios bios boot ein apt ios setup bios version ok was kann man alles einstellen
sata controller smu options was auch immer smu ist system configuration sustain power
limit ich glaube da stellen wir schlicht und ergreifend gar nichts dran ein hardware monitor
bm smart fan function bm stellen wir auch nichts an s5 rtc wake up network stack configuration
gfx configuration ist das das wie viel schert ram die grafika dass ich zieht oder security
boot fixed boot ok ok also die bios settings sind glaube ich die ziemlich rudimentärsten
bios settings die ich einfach gesehen habe du kannst ja legit gar nichts einstellen in
den bios gibt es nicht so was wie temporäres tempo temporäres was da stand noch was unter
gfx nur nur nur die buffersize die umar fb buffersize aber nicht einfach temporär sagen
ich möchte das booten nvme usb bbs priority ok boot boot option eins ist der usb stick
ich sehe schon wir müssen gleich noch mal ins bios ach boot override da ist es moment
da kann der sd karte rein hard disk und als nächstes mal wegen nvme boot override wir
wollen booten usb partition 1 s usb booten please ah da sind wir oh es macht ein sound
alter jetzt übertreibt man nicht mach halt mach halt noch lauter bitte ist ja gut alter
wie kriege ich die musik wieder leiser ok komm wir lassen wir lassen uns von der musik
beschallen viel zu laut ok ich glaube nicht dass die musik tos ist weil tos musik dürften
die nicht mitliefern ok wie installiert man das jetzt vielleicht hätte ich mir mal einen
guide dazu durchlesen sollen ok ich glaube ich muss ein controller anschließen leute
ich glaube ich muss ein controller anschließen seck kurz kurz mal controller jetzt habe ich
irgendwie geschafft den controller wie habe ich es jetzt geschafft das bitteschön um
das kabel zu wickeln das ist doch gar nicht möglich das war eben noch aufgewickelt ok
ok ich will es installieren weil ich will da kein usb stick für ich habe zwei zwei
festplatten drin ok wir haben jetzt ein xbox controller dran ah nice ok menü wir haben
sogar ein kodi media center am start alles klar dass ich gut aus ist das ist der controller
staubig ok kodi haben wir am start exit eben ich habe kodi braucht man da nicht wirklich
aber es ist sehr cool dass es dabei ist ich meine es sind ja keine games dabei es sind
ja nur irgendwelche open source games dabei um zu gucken dass es funktioniert dürfen
natürlich nichts mitliefern ok also was haben wir hier game settings boot into barthus er anpress start to open the main menu navigate to system settings in stock system settings ok mein controller hängt es passiert
einfach gar nichts gerade und jetzt hallo oh was habe ich jetzt was habe ich jetzt gemacht
ok ich glaube muss das nochmal machen systemeinstellung das hat einfach nur ewig geladen eben also information
language englisch uk ok zeitzone europe berlin kokona time format ich will es ehrlich gesagt
einfach nur auf einen neuen wir stellen es mal auf englisch wieder zurück ok install
on new disc storage device internal ok wir haben internal zur auswahl ne internal ist
der usb stick oder ich wusste ich muss die windows ich muss bestimmt das windows noch
ok install a new disc jetzt hängt es wieder ok ich mache jetzt einfach nichts das menü
braucht ein bisschen wahrscheinlich wenn man das erste mal das menü aufmacht muss das
komplett vom usb stick vom usb stick nachladen deswegen werde ich einfach nichts machen bis
sich das menü als geupdatet hat
network required ok das das ergibt natürlich warum warum ist das network required um es
auf einem neuen disc zu installieren just just asking
network da muss ich den switch erstmal einschalten für den switch brauche ich strom und strom
muss ich die lampe ausmachen ok switch dann brauchen wir jetzt noch ein netzwerkkabel
ok wir können gleich mal testen wir können gleich mal testen ob das ding 2,5 g auch erreicht
ich stöpselt es mal an einen 10 g port ran j5 14 gucken ob sich singt mit 2,5 es singt
sich auf jeden fall ich weiß nicht mit wieviel kommt man den barthos sehr auch irgendwie
in die schere also das erste was ich machen werde definitiv ist ssh einschalten so das
einzige was ich gemacht habe mir den install angeguckt
network required ok install on new disc jetzt haben wir es doch passt kannst du direkt in
der gui machen nice werde ich da machen target device hier kingston das ist die on das ist
mein usb stick ein um 690 mini forum also das ist die onboard ssd da kommt das drauf
target muss ich da irgendwas auswählen x86 64 gehe ich mal von aus muss ich auswählen
ich habe nicht die kingston ist die onboard x86 64 guck das da ctmx 500 ist meine ssd alter
solution the fuck hallo leute damit habe ich jetzt nicht gerechnet dankeschön für den
pogu rate was habt ihr gemacht wahrscheinlich habt ihr warzone gespielt und rumgerätscht
jetzt gehts aber los ja installieren dann mal kurze zusammenfassung was wir hier machen
sekunde leute wenn so viele neue leute da sind muss ich mal kurz ein bisschen erzählen
was wir eigentlich gerade hier machen mach mal kurz ich mach mal kurz die beleuchtung
wieder an dass man was gescheites sieht also was wir gerade machen ist folgendes ich switch
mal auf die kamera ich habe mir diesen mini pc hier gekauft den jetzt glaube ich im fullscreen
sehen solltet fortnite trainieren ok so also aber auch rumgerätscht da ich wills mal hoffen
was anderes hätte ich jetzt auch nicht erwartet es ist krass mittlerweile was ist eigentlich
für preisgelder schon so in sagen wir mal so jetzt jetzt in im wie heißt denn das richtig
so in der streaming amateur szene gibt ja da sind ja keine super krassen esl e-sport
events also da tut sich mittlerweile was die meisten streamer turniere haben ja mittlerweile
mehr preisgelder als irgendwelche esl finals einfach weil da mehr kohle drin ist ist schon
heftig so also was wir machen ist ich habe mir mini pc gekauft und zwar ist es ein steht
er hier ein mini forums ich kann ich so wirklich bewegen weil er hinten so viel schitt dran
ist ein mini forums pc ein um 690 er hat unter anderem tatsächlich usb 4 schon man erkennt
es nicht so ganz aber ja so da war gerade ssd eingebaut bzw.
2 ssd ist drinne normale 2,5 zoll ssd ist drinne und das ist ein super kiste zum games emulieren
zum alte konsolen beispielsweise emulieren da kann man bis hoch also angeblich ich hab
es noch nicht ausprobiert ja da kann man angeblich bis zur switch emulieren was man natürlich
nicht darf beziehungsweise doch switch emulieren darfst du du darfst natürlich keine spiele
mit kopierschutz auslesen und umgehen und sowas würden wir im stream natürlich nie
im leben machen und natürlich sind alle meine roms rein selbst gerippt ja also diese kiste
habe ich mir gekauft ist eine kombi cpu ist ein amd ryzen 6900 hx heißt das ding glaube
ich ist eine cpu mit einer grafikkarte drauf was extrem nice ist für den formfaktor ich
zeige euch mal zum vergleich wie groß das ding ist guck mal hier habe ich in meinem
xbox controller ich habe tatsächlich den xbox 360 controller dementsprechend ist er
ein bisschen staubig guck mal also das teil ist quasi so groß wie xbox controller es
ist es ist der xbox controller ist ein bisschen länger aber das ist ein bisschen höher es
hat ungefähr die abmaße von dem xbox controller das heißt es ist relativ relativ klein was
sehr praktisch ist wenn man nämlich und das ist das was ich damit auch vor hab vielleicht
werde ich das auch in einem video verwursten wenn man das ding nämlich hinten an seinem
fernseher montieren will kann man das machen das hat das hat halterung und es hat ein weser
mount dabei das heißt man kann das hinten hinten an fernseher montieren richtig kleine
box hat einen lüfter drinne ist sehr leise also man hört man hört eigentlich gerade
eigentlich hört man hört man gar nichts und es ist für mich was ich so geguckt habe so
die optimale emulator kiste wenn man ein bisschen mehr als super nintendo 64 spielen will also
was ich vor hab ist ich möchte beispielsweise mal wieder mario galaxy und so was spielen
ich will also ich möchte tatsächlich bis hoch zu switch spielen mal ausprobieren aber
hauptsächlich will ich natürlich snes n64 ps1 ps2 wie vielleicht ein bisschen wie du
und eventuell auch ein bisschen switch aber hauptsächlich auch mal bis zur wie inklusive
wie und das coole ist das ding ist so leistungsstark dass du sogar wie spiele nicht nur emulieren
kannst du kannst spiele abscalen auf 1080p theoretisch theoretisch sogar auf 4k aber ich
glaube nicht dass die kiste 4k 4k spiele machen und da sehen spiele wie super mario galaxy
extrem nice aus weil nintendo die spiele deutlich sagen wir mal hochwertiger von den assets
produziert hat als es auf so einer billigen parl auf lösung im fernsehen ausgeschaut
hat also es wirklich extrem nice diese kiste kostet weil ich weiß dass die frage wieder
kommt übrigens für alle die neu sind wenn ihr irgendwas wenn ihr irgendwas habt nicht
antwortet nicht drauf schreibt entwupplos mit in chat das sonst so über sehe ich das
gerade wenn ich hier am basteln bin da am klicken bin da am machen bin ich hab zwar
immer ein auge auf chat aber alles sehe ich auch nicht jo das probieren dann auch gleich
mal aus aktuell bin ich gerade dabei eine ordentliche oberfläche drauf zu insdrehen
also das ist die kiste und wir machen jetzt wir machen jetzt weiter würde ich sagen genau
anschlüsse man hat sogar ein 2,5 g netzwerk port das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch wenn
man da was übers netzwerk drauf kopieren will aktuell verbraucht es eidl weiß ich auch mal
das erkennt guckt mal eidl 12,6 watt ach so du wolltest sagen wie teuer stimmt also in
der in der ausführung wie ich sie habe kostet 800 euro beziehungsweise 850 per amazon ich
kann es euch mal zeigen aber die gibt es auch noch billiger also wenn man nur super nintendo
und n64 emulieren will gibt es das ganze deutlich billiger aber ich will halt alles bis hoch
zur switch machen also wenn ihr wirklich nur die die ganz alten konsolen emulieren wollt
ps 1 s n e s n e s und vielleicht nur ein bisschen n64 dann kommt ihr mit der billigsten
50 euro kiste klar ich will halt ein bisschen mehr machen so guck mal mini pc amd das ist
der neue da kommt ja auch mit sowas hier easy für die ganz alten konsolen easy da könnt
ihr wirklich wirklich ganz ganz billige kleine kisten kisten nehmen also 50 euro pc reicht
für die alten konsolen psp und so reicht reicht easy aus ja wenn man ein bisschen wenn
man wie vielleicht bisschen wie du vielleicht sogar mal ein bisschen xbox oder so haben
will dann braucht es schon ein bisschen bisschen mehr so also in der ausstattung barebone also
sprich wenn ihr selbst ram kaufen wollt falls ihr noch haben habt beziehungsweise falls
ihr ssd habt dann könnt ihr die barebone ausrüstausstattung kaufen das ist dann nur
die grafikkarte und die cpu und halt das also der rechner mit grafikkarte und cpu das ist
ja in einem das ist ja grafikkarte und cpu ist in einem wer wissen will wie das ding
aufgeschraubt aussieht muss ein bisschen zurückspulen im stream kann sich das ja nachher angucken
das hatten wir haben wir schon alles aufgebaut so und ich habe die aus ich habe diese ausstattung
32 gigabyte ram und 512 g ssd ich habe allerdings noch eine alte ssd zusätzlich mit eingebaut
die noch mal 512 g hat also habe ich ungefähr ein terabyte ssd speicherkart da drinnen
die ssd kommt seht ihr ja die kommt hier oben so so rein ja so siehts aus
musik anmachen und ihr könnt entweder hier im shop kaufen da müsst ihr aber noch versand
versand drauf rechnen oder ihr geht bei amazon und bei amazon ist das alles ein bisschen
warum kein steam deck für emulation weil ich was haben will was ich mir hinter dem fernseher
in den fernseher hänge ich weiß ich was ist in dem steam deck drinnen ich gehe davon
aus wahrscheinlich ist das ähnliche hardware wahrscheinlich gar nicht so großartig unterschiedlich
zellner ocarina of time n64 das läuft easy du kannst hier ocarina of time theoretisch
abscaled auf 1440p spielen können wir vielleicht nachher sogar mal ausprobieren was ist in
dem steam deck drinnen ein custom apu vier cores are threads und graphics er den a m
ne das ist ziemlich das ist ziemlich ziemlich das gleiche eigentlich
das ist also der stream deck hat ein bisschen schlechtere cpu aber ja also die kiste hier
hat ein bisschen stärkere cp bis bisschen stärkere cpu als das stream deck und graphics
seht ihr irgendwas zu graphics 1848 wahrscheinlich ist die steam deck grafik hat ein bisschen
besser also unter dem strich wahrscheinlich ist gar kein so groß gar kein so großer unterschied
es ist halt schon klein lässt sich hinter lässt sich hinter den fernseher hängen ok
weiter geht's wo habe ich meinen controller hier jetzt geht jetzt geht die musik wieder
an das ist ja wir mal geht die musik an mal geht's aus so also wir installieren es jetzt
erst mal wohlgemerkt ich hab das selbst benutze das hier also ich hab das selbst noch nie
benutzt ich benutze das zum ersten mal ja das ist auch amd das ist der amd apu quasi
on chip grafikkarte mit drinne also target device wir wollen es installieren auf die interne
m2 ssd also ich hab zwei platten drinne das hier ist der usb stick da sollte man sich
jetzt nicht verklingen ja zwei platten drin einmal eine m2 ssd das die hier unten und
hier eine mx 500 auch nochmal so mit 512 g beziehungsweise genau genommen sind es ja keine gigabyte
sondern sind ja sind ja was gebe beit wie auch immer man sagt ja man sagt ja eigentlich
gar nicht mehr gigabyte weil giga ja 1000 ist und ich 1024 aber das mit 26 hätte ich
oder gibi gibi oder gibi also immer ehrlich das sind so dinger alle programme und tools
können es mittlerweile niemand benutzt das höchstens ich weiß ich falls jemand von euch
fachinformatiker gelernt hat abschlussprüfung bei der irk gemacht hat die fragen so ein
scheiß ja ansonsten fragt es keiner ok wir installieren auf der intern ssd unsere architektur
ist x8664 ist kein raspberry pi und keine irgendwelche anderen single board computer
are you sure wir sind sure working du bist gerade dabei gibi ok ja aber es ist es ist
nicht mibi sondern mibi anscheinend mega wer auch immer sich das ausgedacht hat jo
nice so working an era acute ist ja geil klappt schon wieder klappt schon wieder erste sahne
er ein error ist acute top klappt klappt klappt er richtig gut dann installiere ich mal auf
der anderen ssd vielleicht hat er probleme mit der m2 oder er hat probleme wissen was
auch sein kann was das für eine software ist das ist barthos serra linux das ist ein live
network ist required ach ich leute ich bin ja auch blöd ich habe den switch ausgeschaltet
weil ich die beleuchtung einschalten musste dass ich euch auf der kamera zeigen kann ich
habe nicht genug freie steckdosen ok ich habe nichts gesagt kein wunder das ein error acute
ist der konnte nicht downloaden weil das switch aus war ok switch ist gebootet das ding hat
eine ip install a new disc aber es hat es hat nice nice background sound so also select
auf die kingston ssd architecture are you sure yes install alter geben wir nicht auf
den sack mann ok dann ist das da drauf install was ist das was ist das heckl besserer cake
weight das ist natürlich toll wie gut wie gut das funktioniert ja jetzt übertreibt
man nicht reboot meister reboot hilft ok reboot wie rebootet man das ding denn wie gesagt ich
kenne das kenne das also security frontend developer options wird wahrscheinlich audio
port kodi settings ja ok wer kodi starten will kann das da drauf auch machen user interface
mode information ich will meine ip meine ip wissen falls das möglich ist dass ich mich
da per ssh darauf verbinden kann wo finde ich network settings 2.141 alles klar da loggen
wir uns mal mit linux kurz darauf ein aber da ist das soundtrack im hintergrund was mit
eingeschaltet im switch das müsste eigentlich hinkriegen aber probieren es gleich nochmal
ssh 1 2 2 1 sagt 1 punkt 2.14 yes ach so nee war zur sera default user ssh und die
fall default password war zur sera so richtig schreiben kann was ist die user and password
zur sera linux root und linux ok da wäre ich jetzt hätte ich auch so drauf kommen können
install logs install log was hat er less install install log not enough space what
ist ein dd drauf ja nice dd ist drauf ok dann werde ich erst mal kurz die windows die interne
windows ssd platt machen da kann das auf den usb auf den usb stick laden das ist kein ding
der usb stick hat noch der usb stick hat noch der usb stick ist komisch komisch gemountet
user data ich muss das storage wahrscheinlich umstellen ok jetzt kapiert der hat das iso
gestartet da das iso gestartet eins zu eins das iso gemountet und nicht nicht den restlichen
usb stick weil der usb stick selbst ist oder mal wo ist denn das überhaupt ja der usb stick
selbst also stings ja der usb stick selbst hat es ist eine usb stick überhaupt das ist
das ist die ssd das ist der usb stick der aus irgendwelchen gründen das ist das ist
meine nee was das ist das gemountete ja ok das sda ist die das ist die windows das ist
das ist das windows ding das hier ist usb vermute ich mal sehr sehr weird champ das
ist usb und das ist die normale das ist die normale disk ok nice dann werden wir es jetzt
so machen mkfs x4 wir machen mal die windows die windows partition platt weil das brauche
ich nvme 0 warum geht das nicht mach mal mount was welches soll ich mounten ach nee n1 muss
ich mounten twinkler den den stick warum benutze nicht gpart weil ich per ssh auf live linux
system drauf bin so found it proceed anyway yes mach einfach alles platt ich meine ich
kann ja nicht wirklich was kaputt machen ok nice fdisk das sieht auch schon besser aus
das sind contain well it partition dable das das sieht auch schon besser aus ok
nee ich glaube ich muss einfach das storage im menü umstellen ich glaube ich weiß woran
es liegt dass es nicht geht guckt mal das ist ganz easy was ich machen muss ich vermute
mal ich muss hier in system settings gehen dann auf storage hier storage device dann
sage ich nicht interne warum kann ich nicht auswählen any externe weil er versucht es
ja runter zu laden und das geht nicht eine vm ist zum spielen doch misst install a new
disk target device alter was ist denn das für ein scheiß man ok ich glaube ich muss
mal das wiki lesen warum kann ich das nicht installieren ich habe doch gesagt hier vielleicht
hätte ich das umstellen müssen erstmal any externe dass man da nicht die platte auswählen
kann ich meine wenn ich bei ssh drauf bin kann ich von hand runterladen und drauf die
den das ist auch kein ding das werde ich wahrscheinlich jetzt machen und fertig ok
das mag nicht ich gucke mal ins wiki les user data ist zu klein ja das wissen wir doch
also was haben wir denn war so sehr install user data so ist denn die fehlermeldung war
zu sehr install not enough space an user data i suspect as part of that is trying to install
an update before installing update to my usb ok sag geile antwort ich glaube nicht dass
wir hier großartig mit resize oder so weiterkommen es gibt nicht wirklich was zu resize das ist
quasi das ist das das ist das iso was drauf gedet ist ich meine ich kann es auf die platte
die den vielleicht habe ich es auch verkehrt geflasht und ihr müsst jetzt nicht random
irgendwelche tools ich weiß wie man in uns installiert ich mache das seit 15 jahren verdienen
ein geld damit ich kenne alle tools die man dazu braucht also ihr müsst jetzt nicht übertreiben
ich muss jetzt erstmal rausgehen was er für schmerzen hat also theoretisch mache ich das
richtig ich muss ihm sagen wo er welche storage device er verwenden soll storage device ach
guck mal normalerweise sollten dann die storage devices drinstehen machen sie aber nicht system
reserved sollte da ich reboote das ding jetzt noch mal schnell sollte da nicht ein bisschen
mehr drinstehen ich meine da sollte auch mehr drinstehen als da steht nix drin das kann
es sein dass das ding keine ok wie rebooted man da stand vorhin mehr drin ja glaube ich
glaube ich nämlich auch system sieht einer irgendwie reboot quit restart system ok yes
mal gucken wir kommen wahrscheinlich schon ich meine wenn gar nix hilft dd ich das auf
die platte und fertig
denkt an dass du per save und exit wieder override machen muss
ich habe ein usb stick glaube ich vorher eingestellt jetzt außerdem habe ich die platte ich habe
die platte überschrieben das heißt er muss jetzt eigentlich usb booten gibt sonst nix
du du du du du du du du du ok jetzt mal gucken menu network settings hat er gecheckt system
settings was ist was hat er denn für schmerzen muss ich die kann das sein dass der problem
hat wenn ich direkt auf das device also ich muss es irgendwie positionieren sonst sonst
mag er nicht kann das sein dass er das dass der problem damit hat wenn es ein nackliches
device ist und es nicht positioniert ist ich habe interne und externe die weiß ist also
sollte es sollte eigentlich sollte hier zur auswahl position beziehungsweise eigentlich
sollte das ganze device zur auswahl zur auswahl sein ok kingston ok das wird jetzt wieder
nicht funktionieren ach ja jetzt mag er oder wie alles klar
mal gucken ob es nach dem download noch funktioniert
der wollte mich einfach nur eine viertel stunde lang tibet es ist interessant wie gut reboot
hilft oder leute findet ihr nicht auch reboot hilft immer sehr gut so während der download
ich guck mal ich muss mal ein bisschen chat aufarbeiten ich finde das ui ist mega nice
es ist halt kein ui zum täglich desktop benutzen chat ich habe eine idee weil so viele solution
zuschauer da sind wir fragen mal chat gpt chat gpt wird exter solution wobei ich glaube
heißt einfach nur noch so wirklich wird exter solution das fortnight community turnier
tournament oder so ich kann schreiben nur gewinnen fragezeit mal gucken was gpt dazu
sagt wahrscheinlich sagt da kann ich nicht beantworten sagt einfach gar nix ich denke
sie hat gpt denkt sich gerade doch gpt kann auch deutsch gpt denkt sich gerade was was
will der dude von mir chat gpt kann dort es hat keinen bock hat das datsinn das will
ich nicht beantworten wo kann man das einstellen auf der webseite ich bin mir nicht sicher
ob du es auf der webseite einstellen kannst aber du kannst deine fragen einfach auf deutsch
stellen oder du kannst auch die frage auf englisch stellen und dann sagen answer in
german geht geht geht beides ok aus irgendwelchen gründen hat er jetzt grad keinen bock es
kann auch sein dass es wieder mal überlebt ach jetzt das ich kann nicht sagen ob ein
bestimmtes team oder spieler ein bestimmtes turnier gewinnen wird erfolg im wettbewerb
hängt von vielen faktoren ab einschließlich der fähigkeit und leistung der einsatzspieler
dynamik des teams und dem glück es ist unmöglich die zukunft fair zu sagen ok also selbst
chat gpt weiß es nicht chat gpt ist immer sehr diplomatisch ja aber wie lahm ist der
low download ist das ist das grad irgendwie überlastet die seite alles 2,5 g keck sag
mal will mich veräppeln was ssh keygen minus r not found achso das muss man richtig schreiben
das ist der nutzer funktionen tut er aber was ist das ja was macht es denn für probleme
hier gibt kein gibt keine probleme auf was passiert denn das ding hat irgendjemand plan
abt ne auf was passiert bato sera ja arch alter arch beide way ist es release es gibt
lsb release noch mal es ist ein arsch linux richtiges richtige g jetzt jetzt jetzt was
ist das hier da fuck oder ich ribut jetzt noch mal ich ribut ich ribut jetzt noch mal
ein stöpsel das ding einfach nur an den gigabit port dran und gut ist mal gucken wir mal wenigstens
abkackt wenn ich wenn ich den port wechsel
jetzt geht hier natürlich gar nix mehr gerade wifi symbol oben rechts null ok wir ributen
noch mal also das ist gerade keine allzu schöne installer experience ich hätte jetzt eigentlich
eher vermutet ich drückte auf install das dauert 20 sekunden und es ist installiert
es ist irgendwie größere probleme macht hätte ich nicht gedacht wo ist das problem
ja sehr sehr merkwürdig
du du du du du du du du du du du du du also es ist sehr weird weird champ
der usb stick ist extrem heiß aber mein da muss ja nichts machen gerade ich werde noch
mal kurz mal ausschalten mal einschalten
hat das ding probleme mit meinem stick oder was
aber der anschluss von dem usb stick ist ja wurscht da hat sogar beides usb a und usb
c
muss ja wirklich laufen die musik an und aus machen
soll jetzt aber komm jetzt einfach funktionieren mann ich hab kein bock ich wollte jetzt eigentlich
schon längst gucken ob irgendwelche games funktionieren also menü system settings
ich lasse es jetzt einfach so install a new disk select dahin x64 install ja ist gut mach
download
sag mal was genau hat das ding für schmerz kann mir das irgendjemand was schlüssig erklären
haben die probleme mit dem download gerade oder was ist da los ist die seite von dem
abspacken oder oder was was geht ab
das ist doch auf jeden fall nicht normal ok ok warte mal
vato sera download wir download uns einfach von hand
easy flutscht wie sonst was
so wir müssen jetzt mal irgendwo hingehen mount ist so ok mount def was haben wir denn
hier sd ja nvme nimm was mount def nvme 0 n 1 nach mnt so
mnt jetzt haben wir platz weget bam easy wo ist wo ist dein problem mann
wo ist das problem guck mal hier
ich mein gut der braucht jetzt ein bisschen aber ok
das funktioniert einfach und wisst ihr was noch besser ist ich
brech ich brech das jetzt immer kurz ab wisst ihr was noch einfacher wäre scp download
image dahin slash mnt punkt so
das liegt nicht an wo davon es liegt an dem im server
das hat nichts mit wundervon zu tun das wird den in den
downloads download geschichte sein
wir können mal betop gucken ob er überhaupt was runter liest 17 der neunte outdated für
arch ja arch muss pleading edge sein arch muss eigentlich am 28 ersten quasi schon
auf dem stand vom 29 ersten sein nur nur dann ist richtig
install und disc wir gucken uns mal wiki eintracht von denen an install bar zu sehr
war eine hard drive ssd ok video press a und ins image will be down ja ja
genauso machen wir es ja
es ist es ist sehr wird wird dass es
das image jetzt einfach auf die festplatte den und gut ist
ich mein vielleicht war das image rüber die den doch verkehrt da steht wie das manuell
ins ich will es nicht manuell das soll einfach das soll einfach mit dem install menü funktionieren
etscher ja super das haben wir ja gemacht also im prinzip exakt exakt das gleiche wie
wir auch gemacht haben flash ja einfach einfach das iso rüber gut ist viel mehr viel mehr
verkehrt machen kann man da ja nicht wirklich das packt übelst rum du hast usb imager benutzt
ja und ist doch egal unter der haupe geht das alles rüber ich das ging mir aber doch
erstaunlich schnell ich bin fast am überlegen ob ich es nicht noch mal flaschen sollte weil
der auch nicht resized hat und sowas komm bevor wir jetzt ewig rum machen wir flaschen
den wir flaschen den noch mal mensch logil hype willst du mich willst du mich abfacken
oder was
eine fräse alter leute was ist das für eine was ist das für einen text man das ist nicht
die gleiche software man das muss jetzt sein du bist vielleicht bist du jetzt auch der
größte hardware experte so wir gehen jetzt ich flasht es jetzt noch mal neu ich hab
keine ahnung was das für und weißt du was wisst ihr was wir machen
ich hätte gesagt ich nehme einfach mal einen alten usb 2 stick vielleicht macht er weniger
weniger probleme aber der usb stick ging ja ok ok pass was jetzt wo ich ihn gebannt
habe z.b. getimelt jetzt nehme ich etscher so blum connect so das haben wir etscher ich
hab's ja ich hab's ja da komm wir machen das so gut ok flash from file barthos serra image
target das da select flasch das andere hat schneller geflascht oder doch ich glaub da
ist irgendwas irgendwas ist da schief gegangen vorhin beim flaschen das war erstaunlich schnell
aber dafür läuft die oberfläche problemlos also hat mich auch gewundert
unter der haube machen die tools eh allen dd wir könnten auch von hand ddn also eben
hat er schon verdammt schnell geflascht aber gut das ging wahrscheinlich ich hab das ja
auch mit 4 m b block size das ist wahrscheinlich die hälfte in cash gegangen gut gucken wir
mal ich mein das ist jetzt eine flash geschwindigkeit die lasse ich mir irgendwo noch gefallen ja
die sieht realistischer aus als die 15 sekunden im vorfeld vorher hat sie wirklich mal über
voir fertig geflescht du du du du du waren wir chat gpt noch irgendwas fragen zeigt gerade
nichts ein mach danach noch mal mit dem ursprünglichen tool ich nehme also wenn das jetzt nicht geht
vermute ich das ding hat schmerzen mit dem usb stick warum auch immer dann nehme ich
einen alten usb 2 stick und dann flaschen was da drauf aber ich glaube jetzt geht's
ich gehe davon aus dass das jetzt einfach funktioniert
ich würde mich auch nicht jucken wenn er nicht zurück kommt also so nervige leute geben
echt auf den keks so validating 0w validaten hier nix jetzt blumen
auf geht's ausschalten aus
finished jaja jaja ganz sicher ganz sicher finished da ist nix da ist nix finished alter
sagt bloß ich kann jetzt noch pssh drauf der usb stick ist noch nicht mal der usb stick
ist noch nicht mal drinne ich reboot jetzt mal gucken was passiert leute ja input output
er soll ich glaube ich muss noch mal komplett ausschalten noch mal komplett ein ok also wenn
das wenn das jetzt funktioniert hätte dann würde ich mich doch mit einem lach ich mich
echt kaputt so ist wieder eingeschaltet alles gut aber jetzt bute der wahrscheinlich einfach
gar nicht weil was soll er buten was zum teufel das hat jetzt funktioniert im hintergrund
gerade der hat gerade geflasht die anzeige ist einfach nur für den arsch ich hab den
usb stick nicht drinne leute das ist ja fail mann das ist ja richtig ok so viel doppelt
musik wieder so was haben wir super nintendo classic kong na gut ist nix drauf so jetzt
müssen wir mal schauen was kann man hier alles so einstellen menu weil du es nicht richtig
abwarten kannst naja ich weiß wenn der progress hängt und kein progress mehr kommt da muss
man davon ausgehen dass es nicht funktioniert das ist schlechtes ui design so user interface
mode voll kodi settings ein hardware video output hdmi audio output normal screen rotation
normal splash settings ja auch gut auch overclock storage device internal exe sollte ich da
nicht mehr haben sollte da nicht mehr zur auswahl stehen
was ok ok moment moment moment wartet mal die f-h ok es hat er erkannt also ne da ist
nix rippt das alles gut media hier def sda hier der hat beides erkannt slash slash media
hat er erkannt ist mein moment er hat user data er hat user data auf der ssd
er hat user data auf der ssd und er hat media
das ist mein erster flashvorgang hier das ist mein erster den ich nicht abgewartet
habe kann das sein ja ok und der 165 wird ok das ist der alles da der hat der hat die
beiden platten doch erkannt ist doch alles gut slash media no label no label ich glaube
ich muss sda nur noch mal neu partitionieren da hat er irgendwelche irgendwelche schmerzen
mit dass er dass er probleme mit hat wenn das nicht partitioniert ist aber auf der anderen
seite ich meine ist ok stolle stolle ist alles alles gut müsste müsste eigentlich alles
funktionieren wir können das jetzt wir können das löschen was da drauf ist also das hier
sollte jetzt kein problem machen media noch label so hier müsste ich jetzt theoretisch
alles löschen können oder alternativ you mount media nope ist ist ist busy geht nicht
aber ich kann media no label und hier drin einfach alles löschen weil das ja die nicht
aktive partition ist hoffe ich mal ja weil guck das hier ist
das macht ja keinen sinn dass das doppelt ich habe sie auch auf der ssd installiert ja
also der hätte auch gemeckert jetzt so und jetzt haben wir noch leere zweite platte dran
ist doch alles gut go gut funst jetzt können wir mal ausprobieren ein paar spiele oder
was man noch was man noch so vereinstellung machen kann ins storage device externe interne
pass mal auf wenn ich jetzt wenn ich jetzt den usb stick anstöpsel erkennt er das dann
dass ich ein external storage device angeschlossen habe wahrscheinlich nicht weil das nicht
partitioniert ist du bist wieder da nerv mich jetzt nicht mehr halt ich war busy zurück
ok ok also der der mountet alle interne und den rest zeigt was auch immer muss man gucken
dass ich dass ich die die platte da zum laufen krieg ich gehe mal davon aus dass es wahrscheinlich
jetzt einfach funktionieren wird also jedenfalls bisschen ein bisschen wir alles muss man sagen
so was haben wir sonst noch updates downloads check for updates start update no update available
downloads content downloader da kann man jetzt bilder bilder und irgendwas runterladen dass
ist irgendwas anderes downloader scraper achter leter titel titel und so was runter also quasi
irgendwelche artworks zu games network settings hostname ich kopiere jetzt mal ein paar spiele
drauf wenn ich den windows share krieg hostname game collection settings sound settings user
interface ok wo macht man stellt man hier macht mir samba ein und aus jetzt gesagt
network settings da muss man ins wiki gucken bei denen ja warum das wifi icon samba ist
immer an ok das heißt im endeffekt probieren wir mal aus da ist eins für eins aha achja
bei roms muss wahrscheinlich der ganze kram rein snes probieren wir mal ok ich glaube
es gibt für mobile auch ein paar retro emulatoren natürlich nicht in dem umfang roms snes ähm
kopiert man dann eigentlich war zur samba roms bin ich macht es überhaupt richtige verzeichnis
ne ne ne ne ne ich will es
ok wir probieren wir probieren mal ich versuche da mal ein game hin zu kopieren also ich habe
hier einen ordner snes so kann ich da einfach einfach die roms rein kopieren mal ausprobieren
nehmen wir mal nehmen wir mal ein super mario world
snes super mario world oder super mario kart
alter wie lahm ist denn der samba share gerade ok kopieren wir mal rüber roms snes
copy hier also probieren wir mal aus ob es funktioniert
obs falscher controller also snes nö wo muss ich die games hin kopieren
game swan update library
äh wo in settings oder wo habt ihr das gesehen
im settings update game list
wie es einfach funktioniert und sogar und sogar relativ relativ gut zum original ausschauen
poggers ok el gato sagt sie haben ja kein input lag
bei instant instant capturing naja so instant ist es jetzt also ich merke gerade bei so
2d platformer zeug merkt man schon den unterschied ja also es hat schon ein bisschen verzögerung
boar ist es alle laggy laggy das das leckt das hat keine vier fps das läuft exakt flüssig
50 60 fps ok das funktioniert wie kommt man ins menü zurück
welches wie kommt man ins menü zurück also xbox button ist es start und select ne start
und ne ah start und xbox taste ahja ok gut zu wissen
so probieren wir noch mal was anderes aus haben wir noch ein paar sachen zum testen
also super nintendo das super nintendo funktioniert dachte ich mir das dürfte eigentlich kein
problem sein probieren wir mal probieren wir mal einen
nintendo ds aus wir mal nintendo ds aus also was wie war das jetzt noch mal menu game settings
update game list nintendo ds ein spiel system is missing oh fuck da braucht man irgendwelche
extra dinger für die muss ich auch alle selbst rippen vom original das wird nicht funktionieren
missing bios files b moment warum funktioniert es trotzdem
also anscheinend funktioniert das einfach ok ds ds ist halt ein bisschen doof ds ist
halt ein bisschen doof zu spielen ok jetzt geht kein button mehr alles klar jetzt ist
jetzt ist broken jetzt jetzt geht kein oh jetzt ist ripp was auch immer ich glaube so
ein bisschen so ein bisschen haupte die musik funktioniert aber hier tut sonst kein knopf
ich glaube das ist glaube das ist broken aber komisch also zumindest zumindest die emulation
an sich funktioniert das intro intro funktioniert ja hier funktionen auch übrigens alle tasten
im intro noch ich kann start machen start drücken aber hier geht einfach nichts mehr
ach hier moment ich hab da grad sowas gesehen da ist grad durchs bild so vom analog stick
guck mal da ach du scheiße man was ist das ich halte mein stylus ja
ach du scheiß ok das ist das also ds kannst du vergessen
oh das ist nicht das ist nicht spielbar das ist nicht spielbar ds kannst du klicken
aber gut touch controls ist halt auch müll ich hab sogar noch ein original ds also würde
ich es lieber da drauf so ok passt nice dns funst wir können noch mal also ich hätte
noch wir müssen mal gucken wie das upscaling unsere funktioniert ne das ist barthus derer
ok n64 wir probieren wir probieren noch mal n64 und dann probieren wir mal mario galaxy
so habe ich ne ach guck mal der n64 ist gar nicht drauf
da muss ich die game collection erst importieren dass es erscheint
all games f0 switch games kann man nicht auslesen ok das lässt sich spielen
einfach nur gucken wie gut es läuft august graphics
das läuft richtig gut ich meine ich habe lag ich habe übelsten ich habe übelsten
steuerungs übelsten steuerungs lag wegen der capture karte aber es läuft es läuft
richtig gut wie macht man jetzt game settings upscaling game options advanced game options
video mode aha hier kann man upscaling guckt mal mal gucken mal gucken ob das damit was
zu tun hat überhaupt auto was kannst du noch alles einstellen also wir können jetzt wir
können jetzt quasi sagen 4k ist klar ne ne komm wir machen mal 1440 p 120 herz mehr
kann meine capture karte glaube ich nicht hier anzeigen so weiter unten war texture
upscaling anti-aliasing dings texture wo ist was mit 120 herz warum nicht 120 herz man also
ich glaube nicht dass das spiel intern mit 120 herz laufen wird das das wird dann komplett
komplett kaputt gehen aber hier kann man jetzt einstellen dass es vielleicht irgendwelche
bei 16 bitgames irgendwelche filter drüber macht also man können hier texture upscaling
textures wir machen wir machen es mal ohne mal gucken ob das überhaupt läuft also viel
besser abgescaldet sieht es jetzt nicht aus ist jetzt irgendwie higher highress ok das
kann man wahrscheinlich in dem game nicht richtig erkennen das ist die eigene katze
alle wie ich krass ist alles mega lecke hyper leg ok keine autos besser abgescaldet ist aber
wie auch immer also n64 funktioniert auch schon mal ganz nice jetzt jetzt bin ich wirklich
mal gespannt wie das mit mario galaxy aussieht mario galaxy ordentlich funktioniert wie mario
galaxy ist ein bisschen größer gehen wir mal ins menü man kann wir müssen das dann auch
probieren wie das mit achievements ist weil man kann ja so man kann ja retro aktiv da
jetzt also nachträglich kann man irgendwelche achievements reinpatchen also reinpatchen
ist jetzt falsch gesagt da wird in das spiel wird nichts reingepatcht das ist in online
bestenliste integration wie das funktioniert so also game collection settings ne nicht
game collection settings game settings update game list yes wii jo
hat das lua support keine ahnung er sieht nach dem wii game aus ich habe natürlich
keine keine die wii fernbedienung habe ich sogar noch ok wie kriege ich wie kriege ich
den input hin jetzt ich habe einfach mal start communicate press a ja gut wie mache ich das
jetzt mit meinem controller wie kann ich wie kann ich da so tun als hätte ich ne we mode
du brauchst ja in mario galaxy die we mode nicht du brauchst sie zum springen und wie
tue ich so als hätte ich ne we mode gar nicht ja also was er gehen tut das bestimmt ok
das muss man bestimmt in game settings machen
ja wie ne emulate emulate we mode on ok komm mal mal
mal gucken ob das besser funktioniert aha ok oh jetzt haben wir oh guck mal ich hab
ich kann we mode faken das das das funktioniert erstaunlich gut connect to players ok da muss
man bar tozera wiki gucken tozera wiki wii aha so alter ist ja klar
emulate use your gamepad like a vertical we mode in game ja das ist schön und gut aber
er denkt ja ich habe ich habe in der we mode nix angeschlossen
ahja hier emulate we mode side way und nandchak und airstick ok das brauchen wir das habe
ich die falschen settings genommen dafür
advanced game options ja das da customer we mode we mode side way emulate we mode sideways
classic controller emulate
swing ok probieren probieren wir es mal so aus
ich glaube jetzt hat er wieder keine keine verbindung zu we mode das merke ich schon
weil so langsam weil so langsam lädt wenn so langsam lädt denkt er ich muss das meine
we mode noch anschließen jetzt wird er wird er gleich sagen gibt keine connection connection
zu we mode vielleicht muss ich beides einschalten vielleicht vielleicht muss ich beides einschalten
dass das funktioniert ja wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich muss ich so machen was kann man hier sonst
noch einschalten upscaling rendering resolution ne moment rendering resolution oh geil da
kann man das müssen wir gleich ausprobieren da kann man upscaling kommen wir upscaling
gleich mal auf 1440 p 1440
ist auf jeden fall nice auf we
jetzt geht's auf fack a und b x und y what ok den controller muss man auf jeden fall
umbelegen so kann niemand das spiel spielen mit dem rechten stick und x das ist ja das
ist ja komplett das ist ja komplett unspielbar ok jetzt kommt storytime wie leute falls jemand
von euch gerade im wiki ist wie kann man selbst machen in game es muss irgendwie xbox button
oder start lange drücken irgendwas in der richtung muss es das ist wie man kann garantiert
selbst machen also auf jeden fall nicht nicht der xbox button vielleicht der xbox button
länger drücken ne xbox button plus x selbst und wie kann man auch kann man auch ein menü
aufmachen xbox button plus a oh ah das ist pause xbox leute das ist höhere render auflösung
erzählt mir mal nix das ist höhere render auflösung das sieht deutlich deutlich schärfer
aus als im original guck mal hier das sieht richtig gut aus
das sieht richtig gut aus ich mein hier fällt ihr halt guck mal an dem gras an dem gras
fällt einem halt auf dass es halt nicht wirklich notwendig war das höher zu machen also höher
auflösend weil es gibt halt auf dem fernsehen bei 500 was ist das 720 x 576 auflösung geht
halt nicht so viel sieht aus wie auf der konsole never sieht das aus wie auf der konsole im
leben sieht es nicht aus wie auf der konsole das overlay sieht aus wie auf der konsole
die render auflösung ist viel höher ich glaube ich glaube die leute haben im haben im kopf
deutlich deutlich zu hoch wie die wie ausgesehen hat das ist sowas von abscaled also es läuft
auch wirklich gut abscaled ich meine wir spielen das ganze hier gerade in 1440 p kann man sich
nicht beschweren was war save state x also spielen kann ich mit den controller belegung
allerdings nicht die controller belegung sind die also auf x zum beispiel mit springen und
so also das ist das ist schon auf jeden fall ein bisschen guck mal das ist ein original
cinematic guck mal wie schlecht das cinematic aussieht versus das video kenne ich guck mal
wie low rest ist cinematic ist und das soll schon besser aussehen wie den gamecraft grafik
das cinematic ist halt einfach gerendert halt auf ntsc und fahrlauflösung kann man sich
skippen nope wird nicht wird nicht geskippt ich will gerade noch mal warten bis man bis man ins
weltall kommt und wie das wie das aussieht was haben wir noch xy was oh safe jetzt muss ich
bin es nochmal angucken shit mann mal x ist es safe state und hier selbst dann reloaded ok und b was ist b ab ist restart ok aber
save states ist natürlich eine äußerst nice sache man hatte das game irgendwie nur zwei verschiedene
inputs acht verschiedene richtungen ok geskippt geskippt wird nicht so kann man
was bin ich sehend die vr variante oder wie screenshot select ich drücke einfach mal alle
tasten ich habe keine ahnung selected slot select slot zwei leute ich habe keine ahnung was
ich da gerade mache aber aber selbst jetzt selbst jetzt sind schon mal äußerst praktisch
ich kann quasi zwei selbst selbst state slots haben dass ich quasi nicht immer immer überschreiben
muss sondern das ist auch praktisch alle tasten zum vorsprung habe keine tastatur dran aber das
intro geht ja schnell auf youtube ne auf youtube nicht du kannst den stream laden nicht auf
youtube du kannst im archiv angucken oder als wort angucken so also muss ja ich sagen die
steuerung ist ziemlich ziemlich verkorkst ja ans wasser springen kann man gar nicht wie mache ich
mein spin wie mache ich eigentlich mein shake gar nicht und der input ist auch also
guck mal die die steuerung mit dem xbox controller die geht gefühlt nur in acht
verschiedene richtungen den den ich glaube ich habe diesen den spin schampen auch gar nicht
glaube das gibt es ich glaube das gibt es erst wenn man wenn man den luma kriegt wenn ich das
richtig im hinterkopf hab ja mario story keckel wobei ich sagen musste ohne scheiß mario galaxy
war für mich das beste 3d mario das beste 3d mario und es hatte irgendwie eine halbwegs
weißt du so ein bisschen bisschen mehr engaging story als die anderen doch du brauchst das hier
das hier mario galaxy eins finde ich persönlich ist besser 3d mario braucht man für den spin
schampen nicht die remote ja doch theoretisch schon aber ich habe das ich habe das ja gemapt
auf mein controller ich weiß nur nicht auf welchen knopf ich will jetzt noch schnell
mal selbst machen wenn wenn die ganze cutscene geschichte vorbei ist aber wie flüssig das
läuft oder also jetzt ist grad cutscene das macht kein aber drumherum gibt es echt nichts
zu meckern abs abgescaled auf 1440 p und das läuft flüssig wie viel watt zieht er ich
guck mal kurz 24 24 watt auf was für einem gerät läuft das ein um 690 mini forum um 690
massive story twist aktuell ist ja nur cutscene warte mal ab bis du bist du in game grafik
siehst ich finde das sieht richtig gut aus also im vergleich zu damals auf der wie also
die auflösung ist ja so viel höher nein ein raspberry pi 4 schafft es nicht warum
heißt es mini forum weil der hersteller sich halt gedacht hat ein guter name ist let's
play oder jetzt kommt dieses doofe tutorial kann ich mir noch dran erinnern jump mit a
nein ich jump nicht mit a ich jump mit x und und der xbox controller ist irgendwie komisch
komisch gemapt intro also ich bin also ohne miss das spiel sieht richtig gut aus für
dass das ist ein spiel ist abscaled oder also dass sie also ich muss halt auch sagen
mario mario galaxy hat so von dem vom art style und dann dieser gesamten machart gibt
es da halt nichts was ich an der grafik auszusetzen habe das ist halt sehr sehr rundes rundes
gesamtbild guck mal ich drücke gerade komplett nach rechts oft auf der auf der fernbedienung
und die ist echt nice speichern wir mal hier können wir kurz raus was ausprobieren wenn
man die auflösung wenn man die auflösung von hand umstellt das irgendeine auswirkung
hat advanced gaming options aber was haben wir hier dolphin libretro dolphin ok gibt's
also video mode wir nehmen mal das gleiche wie 1440 p 120 hertz was gibt's hier heads
up display rumble rumble brauchen wir nicht 16 zu 9 konnte da schon ich muss auf jeden
fall die die dinger umlegen uber shaders may not work well oder was ok was macht uber shader
siehts da noch geiler aus oder ok hybrid uber shaders
16 fach anti lasing bamm es geht volle pulle ja das reicht ok mal gucken ob es jetzt ob
das jetzt irgendwie den unterschied macht gleich wir müssen es jetzt noch mal nicht
noch mal angucken wir können ja einfach laden wieder xbox tasten und epsilon wir haben es
kaputt gemacht und jetzt ruckels ok leute es sieht ex es sieht noch mal viel viel geiler
aus aber es hat so ein paar leichte leichte performance probleme
kleine performance probleme
ich hab natürlich jetzt mehrere sachen umgestellt mehrere sachen umgestellt ich weiß nicht
woran es gelingen aber ich muss probieren klein noch ein paar andere sachen aus nämlich
also wir machen jetzt erstmal die lasing geschichten
so ich will es auf auto stellen so mal gucken ob das die uber shaders sind die da was auch
immer das ist wenn die musik von der frame rate abhängt ganz ehrlich wenn ich auf überall
immer also wenn ich mich drauf verlassen könnte dass ich immer auf der gleichen hardware laufe
und so warum nicht ok ne das kannst du knicken geht doch eigentlich leute das sieht das sieht
einfach mal so viel besser aus als auf der konsole damals man richtig nice also da kann
man sich echt nicht beschweren das ist wirklich sehr hübsches game immer noch so jetzt testen
wir mal aus wie das mit mit einem bluetooth controller ist weil ich habe ja moment kann
der xbox kann der überhaupt bluetooth xbox one controller kann der bluetooth
die ersten nicht f f xbox one controller 2003 ich hab nen release controller
second revision ok der release day controller nicht aber wir können einfach mal den ps4
controller ausprobieren ok alles klar das geht anscheinend nicht
ich hole mal den ps4 controller ob wir den irgendwie pairn können hatten die ersten
ps4 controller wenigstens bluetooth ps4 controller alle ok dann probieren wir das aus sekunde
ich hole mal ein
wo habe ich den muss ich jetzt erstmal aufladen aber machen wir halt am pc ist ja kein problem
wo wo wo wo wo wo wo wo wo wo ich weiß nicht was da für musik läuft aber muss ja free
musik sein weil sonst wäre die da nicht gebandet so mal kurz micro usb hier dran ich hab nur
so ein komisches adapter kabel das wird schon tun so aufladen jawoll erled ok wie pairt
man das ding per bluetooth das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken wahrscheinlich muss man
dann menu game collection controller und bluetooth settings pair a bluetooth device forget bluetooth
show controller activity pair bluetooth device searching for device ok wie funktioniert
das was muss ich jetzt machen pairing ist ist das das ist das jetzt gepaert ok jetzt
muss ich erstmal gucken wie man diesen komischen controller den sony controller in den pairing
modus setzt ok pairing failed ja ja per ps4 controller bluetooth while pressing and holding
the share button press and hold the ps button until the light flashes ok while pressing
and holding share button press hold ok machen wir share button der share button pair controller
already running erzähl doch nix share button share button und jetzt muss ich den ps controller
halten ah pairing shield what nein soll sich das shield pairen das ist der falsche das
ist das falsche bluetooth gerät ja pairing fail ja klar pairing fail
ah wireless controller connected nice ok das war tatsächlich relativ easy easy jetzt
habe ich mal jetzt habe ich wireless den den den ps4 controller cool ok das ging easy
it eats bluetooth äußerst pogu ok das war einfach ich muss mal kurz den sound ein kleines
tippchen also was moin ich hatte letzte woche ein wenig stress mit einem meiner lehrer aufgabe
war ein shell skip zu erstellen welches user erstellt diese das password nach der anmeldung
ändern müssen ich habe ich habe folgende befehle für den user ok das wüsste ich das
wüsste ich aus dem kopf gar nicht ob man das so moment du brauchst warum musst du warum
musst du nach einem user noch noch ach so dass die nach der anmeldung ändern müssen
also ad user und user ad ist ja so ein bisschen unterschiedlich je nach os ad user ist normalerweise
mit anlege script und user ad nicht oder umgedreht kann sich keiner merken ansonsten müsste ich
es mir im detail angucken also das jetzt also du musst das auf jeden fall wenn du es beim
ersten lass mal überlegen was du überhaupt machen wenn du es beim ersten login geändert
haben willst wahrscheinlich gibt es da nicht irgendeine fertige option schon beim anlegen
dass der das der nach dem ersten mal einloggen dass der dann irgendwas in die in die profiles
schreibt oder weiß ich aus dem kopf auch nicht ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung wie man
das gescheit macht das problem ist eigentlich ist es komplett irrelevant in der praxis also
man stellt keine linux systeme zur verfügung wo dann irgendwie 20 user interaktiv mit eigenen
konten und so das hat man vielleicht früher mal gemacht aber die leute haben alle ihren
user können dann sudo machen und fertig also keine ahnung weiß ich aus dem kopf nicht
wie man wie man einstellt dass der user direkt nach dem ersten log in sein password ändern
muss aber das kann man mit sicherheit extrem easy googeln wir können mal wir können mal
chat gpt fragen was sie dazu sagen was sie dazu sagen chat gpt wo macht man das denn
noch wo hast du wirklich so einen remote remote multi user system shell only vor allem wer
macht denn so was heute noch super computer ja ok man findet immer irgendwelche nischen
beispiele wo man doch die irgendwelche funktion braucht aber wer macht bitte schon super
computer da gibt es gibt es ein paar leute das machen aber es ist nicht der alltag lasst
mal das mal chat gpt fragen wir fragen wir fragen fragen chat gpt sogar mal auf deutsch
ja wie kann man unter linux wie formulieren wir das überhaupt den user zwingen sein password
zu ändern nach dem ersten log in chat gpt kann ein bisschen über überladen es gibt
verschwinden unter ihr einen benutzer zu zwingen sein password beim ersten anmelden zu ändern
password pass wd-e zu verwenden und das ablaufdatum des pass aha ok das klingt sinnvoll einfach
auf abgelaufen setzen und gut ist was shake shake habe ich noch nie gehört jetzt jetzt
chat jetzt wissen was password minus also pass wd-e ablauf quasi password abgelaufen
setzen und dann beim nächsten log in passport ändern feifert wusste ich auch nicht ich
muss in 15 minuten ausklauen das wollte ich jetzt noch machen also wir haben das jetzt
im chat was irgendwas wollte ich doch gerade gucken wie man achso wie lädt man wie lädt
man denn für die games jetzt eigentlich artworks und sowas runter game collection setting system
displayed a scraper scrape from screen scraper scraper settings ja das gut systems included
wie gut und wie sage ich jetzt scrape scrape now
ach scrape now da unten sogar ein knopf null ach da muss man sich einloggen errors moment
was für ein ding errors the login very viel less identifier ultra saurus games db scrape
genau geoff screen scraper punkt fr haben wir noch zur auswahl games db hf s db alles
klar du kannst ja noch die themes angucken ich wollte eigentlich jetzt weiß wieder was
ich was ich was ich gucken wollte ich wollte gucken retro achievements retro achievements
wie das funktioniert hat retro achievements.org retro achievements barthosera wie man das einrichtet
retro achievements retro achievements allows you to game settings retro achievements
game settings
hat er jetzt eigentlich wollen lassen wir kurz gucken ob der hat er keine artworks zu
gefunden ok rango was so teufel rango der ist bisschen durcheinander gekommen mit den
harteinnahmen moment game settings retro achievements retro achievements setting ja ds ist wirklich
schwierig retro achievements enabled hardcore mode we both mode rich presence ok challenge
indicators ok unlock unlock sound aber man kann sich leider nicht anhören xbox achievement
das brauche ich blim blim ach hier muss man username und so eingeben ok retro achievements
muss ich mir mal kurz registern register kann man xbox gamer scroll sammeln nee aber so
was ähnliches traffic lights jawoll excellent excellent fr hieß das ding oder screenscraper
fr register ich regisse mich gerade mal testweise mit einer fake email adresse ja inzwischen
ablager kopieren username sag email konfirm email password nein nein nein ok
register röhr an email has been sent ok screen dings register wo ist in den register knopf
leute register ok using a shared account is prohibited and will result in your ip automatically
banned monka es ich will keine account share ok register so
omae alles jetzt funktioniert kann man das vielleicht in gescheiter sprache irgendwie
haben dass ich was verstehe hat es das login funktioniert
ach nee hier registriert man sich n voyeur n voyeur
retro achievements ist am start welits jawoll welcome
ach nee moment username ok yes also mein username ist offensichtlicher könnte er nicht sein
ich leg mir eh einen neuen an mit einer ordentlichen email adresse dran man kann die sprache auswählen
wo ach da lenken sogar auf deutsch englisch ist schon ok in die zwischenblatt kopieren
ach hier ist register sign up username jawoll beste omae
i accept ich accepte alles ok sehr schön also dann machen wir das doch mal wir usernamen
bester bester usernamen überhaupt 6 7 8 6 7 1 4 alles klar ok password oh nee leute
ihr dürft jetzt nicht gucken ich hoffe dass es nachher nicht im klartext
da steht ok das password ist zum glück nicht
ok game game settings update game list yes so hat es jetzt irgendwas getan hier
ach komm mal jetzt haben wir achievements jetzt haben wir achievements zum anlocken
ok das findet das natürlich nicht weil das game so komisch heißt also müssen wir mal
nach mario galaxy suchen ok was auch immer wie ging das wie ging das andere jetzt noch
hier scrape settings scrape from screenscraper screenscraper settings wie lockt man sich
da ein usernamen ach schau wieder aber mein es sollte doch hier mario galaxy drin sein
man viel wir gehen mal hier meta meta daten
oh alter was edit this games meta data rango ja genau rango ich habe leider nichts angeschlossen
das ordentlich galaxy ok ok jetzt sollte jetzt sollte er ja was finden oder scrape rango
was will er als mit rango mann was geht jetzt auf input ah ups was jetzt ich dachte ich
kann jetzt ich kann es löschen oder rango ach so ok ok ich weiß jetzt nicht was ich
gemacht habe was habe ich jetzt kaputt gemacht irgendwas irgendwas habe ich jetzt gebraked
weil ich auf reset gegangen bin rango vielleicht mache ich erst noch mal save jetzt gehe ich
noch auf scrape ah ok rango ok hier bin ich nicht eingeloggt aber guck mal hier die haben
viel mehr infos da drüber aber gut das ist schon mal nice das ist schon mal cool so dass
das funktioniert sehr schön moin patrick das ist richtig cool das gefällt mir ich habe
sogar jetzt den wireless den wireless controller für die ps4 am start und das game sieht einfach
mal so viel besser aus als im original ist echt krass hätte ich nie gedacht jetzt kann
ich sogar das unterstützt sogar zwei player mit dem zweiten controller guck mal das kann
ich mit dem zweiten controller man kann sogar die multiplayer dinger spielen mega nice weil
die multiplayer option in mario galaxy waren waren extrem unsinnig die steuerung ist halt
ein bisschen pepega vor allem weil es halt wow first person view mit input lag mit dem
wii spiel sieht das fucking gut aus zumal dass er nicht für third person gedacht ist
mit input lag ist halt das spielen etwas ich meine ich spiele jetzt ja auch über die capture
card und nicht aber guckt euch mal die grafik an das ist so viel besser als auf der wii
richtig poggers ne ne ne ne das liegt nicht an der emulation der input lag das liegt daran
dass über die capture card spiele ich spiele hier über so einen so einen ich wette ich
wette wenn ich das direkt am monitor habe ist da nichts mit input lag das hat kein input
lag so das soll so krass das klappt auf jeden fall besser als über die capture karte über
die capture karte über irgendein aufnahmeprogramm wie hoch ist die auslastung ist eine gute
frage gucken wir mal kurz während während das läuft während das läuft da wird nichts
input lecken da kein fall also top ja geht eigentlich hält sich hält sich stark in
grenzen die auslastung cpu ja gut 16 kerne ist auch ein bisschen gbait es sind ja eher
acht oder was handeln reisen 6.000 ja ja mit halber threading 16 alles klar alles klar
verstehe so wie im moment jetzt weiß ich ja welches game das ist und wie kriege ich
jetzt dies mit wie kriege ich jetzt die achievements dafür raus oder gibt es dafür gar keine achievements
für mario galaxy das kann natürlich sein gucken wir mal retro achievements retro achievement
games die meinen retro wirklich ernst die meinen retro wirklich so richtig retro also
maximal bis n64 ds die wie kriegt keine achievements
soll aber bald kommen ok all games mal gucken vielleicht steht ja auch unter all games all
games die seite die seite sieht die heißt nicht nur retro hat es vielleicht mal eine
ordentliche suche hier mario galaxy wenn er so richtig schreiben könnte läuft da auch
ein xbox emulator drauf theoretisch schon ja aber ich habe gerade kein xbox game da
für den ds wurde gesagt für den ds gab es das nie 3d platforming 0 achievements ok gibt's
nicht also du kannst du kannst darauf tatsächlich wohl ganz gut auch xbox emulieren und xbox
360 xbox 360 geht tatsächlich auch aber ich habe keine xbox spiele also ich habe ich
habe 50 originale xbox 360 spiel oder so hier aber keines gerippt das ist ja auch kein
raspberry pi lull raspberry pi würde würde auch ein wii spiel nicht abscaled auf 1044
spiel laufen es ist so nice das gefällt mir richtig gut mein kodi brauche ich nicht das
habe ich auf meinem schild auf meinem schild tv laufen gibt's chat gibt's auch irgendwas
was ich ausprobieren soll themes ok das können wir ausprobieren was hat er pc für specs
so
also was der pc für specs hat kann ich dir zeigen das ist ein mini forum um 690 der hat
einen also ich habe die kombination hier der hat ein ryzen 6900 hx das ist quasi cpu und
gpu in einem und 32 gigabyte ram 512 g ssd und ich habe noch eine zweite 512 g ssd die
ich noch hatte eingebaut hier specs siehst du acht course 16 threads das ist genauso
der richtige wie soll man sagen so richtig das ist auch der grund warum ich mir den
gekauft habe und jetzt also genau der richtige sweet spot für emulation du bezahlst irgendwas
zwischen 500 800 euro schneller haben willst vielleicht ein bisschen mehr je nachdem welche
ausstattung du kannst natürlich auch wenn du dich mit alten systemen mit alten systemen
zufrieden gibst kannst du was viel viel billigeres kaufen ja da reicht jeder 50 euro pc reicht
da 50 euro billig aliexpress kiste aber das hat eine super geschichte weil das ist preislich
okay für das was man bekommt und es ist zum ersten mal jetzt schön kompakt möglich grafik
power und gpu power in einem zwar meine kiste ist ich habe es ich habe es euch ja ich kann
es euch ja mal schnell zeigen kommt mal die kiste ist im endeffekt die ist die ist kleiner
davon also von den atmen kleiner als ein ps4 controller und unten oben ein bisschen länger
also die kiste ist ist wirklich guck mal meine hand zum verkleid also die kiste ist wirklich
klein so du bekommst du bekommst eine ordentliche grafikkarte also mobile grafikkarte ist keine
richtige grafikkarte also es ist eine integrierte also es ist keine dedicated auch keine dedicated
mobile es ist halt so eine so eine apu cpu und gpu in einem die sind aber in dieser generation
zum ersten mal so dass man damit ordentlich was spielen kann damit kann man übrigens
auch theoretisch pc gaming betreiben halbwegs halbwegs also ganz zum beispiel das neue doom
drauf spielen ganz gut in mittleren details und und 1440 p mit 60 fps und das geht ganz
gut aber ich habe es ja ich habe sie überhaupt nicht für pc gaming für pc ps3 geht damit
auch aber da muss ich erstmal bios runterladen es geht damit alles es geht damit alles sofern
der emulator ist halt unterstützt gerade xbox 360 emulator sind ein bisschen naja aber du
kannst alles damit also alles was es gibt kannst du damit emulieren du kannst theoretisch auch
press auf the wild spielen mit drei aber dann glaube ich maximal du kannst abscalen und dann
hast du es dann aber bloß auf 1080p was schon mal besser ist als original aber gut das ist
das ist eine super emulation kiste sondern du kriegst du kriegst 32 g ddl 4 ram ssd und
2 2 hdmi ausgänge was vielleicht ganz praktisch ist für manche und du hast 2,5 gigabit ethernet
für netzwerk also wirklich wirklich coole kiste ps3 geht ps3 funktioniert sogar abscale auf der
kiste leute wenn ich eine ps3 wenn ich eine ps3 ps3 rom hätte beziehungsweise bios files
dann würde ich euch zeigen aber habe ich nicht also wirklich mega mega nice nice kiste pogu
extrem extremely pogu ich bin übrigens 38 by the way nur für den fall der fälle dass
ich jemand wundert warum ich extremely pogu sage so bekannt das 38 jährige das auf der welt ist
das normal dass sie das sagen alle sie sollt ich noch mal schnell ausfüllen so user interface
settings theme configuration du meinst ich soll hier mal durch switchen mehr gibt's nicht mehr
gibt's die wo bekommt man neue themes her
muss man mal muss man mal suchen würde ich sagen
war toserra themes
themes gibt es auch ein theme downloader oder sowas arcade planet du glaubst bei
downloader du meinst hier updates und downloads themes ach ja tatsächlich easy
ok was was sieht mir ganz cool aus alex voll install
geh aufs klo warum soll ich aufs klo gehen
vor allem weil es interessiert dich das so sehr ob ich aus ob ich aufs klo gehe oder nicht ich
streame seit viereinhalb stunden ist richtig install art flix install artbook das sieht
nix aus kommen installieren einfach mal ein paar themes wie viele gibt's denn da
schon bis sie was ich schon auf fakt das hört ja gar nicht auf alter
habe ich schon runtergeladen so themes
was ist was ist das default es es theme kabon carbon ist das default
hast du gigabit ne alex voll auch nicht schlecht
auch nicht schlecht sie also muss echt sagen die oberfläche ist wirklich wirklich sehr gut
gelungen und gemacht so das haben wir hier kontrolle kontrolle user interfaces alex ng
so rum
ich finde es wirklich sehr sehr stylisch sehr stylisch gemacht alles
so jetzt gucken wir uns mal gelb user interface
content oder ok das sind irgendwelche
leute super tocs ich dachte ich dachte es gibt so super tocs card
super tocs card als beste art art flix hatten wir noch
ach das ist das was wir gerade ausprobiert haben schon das da art flix ist das erste
was wir ausprobieren das fand ich persönlich jetzt wirklich nicht schlecht art flix aber das
muss man glaube ich einfach mal durch einfach mal durch testen glaubt das muss man echt
einfach mal durch testen alles letztendlich ist es ja nur das hauptmenü der reste der rest
ist ja immer das immer das gleiche ok das ist das ist für die für die mini minimalisten unter uns
ok die bedient sich ein bisschen bei kodi kannst du übrigens auch starten wenn du willst also wenn
man wenn man jetzt auf fernsehen gucken will und irgendeine pvr kiste kann man auch fernsehen
draufgucken will ich aber nicht weil dann gehe ich einfach auf meine auf mein schiel tv guck mir
das an also die oberfläche fühlt sich wirklich gut an also ich könnte ich könnte jetzt zum
beispiel ein gibt kein pvr kleint alles klar ok man kann kein fernsehen gucken hier drauf weil
die pvr agents wohl fehlen alles klar kann man nicht mal kein pvr alles klar leute exit bar to
sera nicer stream richtig cooles software auch auch mega produkt dass es so einfach geht mit
controller pern und sowas shutdown system ich werde jetzt natürlich noch mal einen
ordentlichen account machen ich werde es nicht mit dem fake account betreiben es war aber auf
jeden fall nice dass ihr dabei wart auch ich ich hoffe dass es auch den den übrig gebliebenen
zuschauen vom solution gefallen hat ein bisschen was anderes kein fortnight rage
dann hätte ich überhaupt kein bock drauf also bettel royal ist das so gar nicht meins
aber gut leute wir sehen uns bis denn ich gehe jetzt aufs klo und ich gehe was essen bis
dann macht's gut zu